Ich habe etwas auf Karten geschrieben und dann... Karten?
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 100. Die hundertste Ausgabe von Chaosradio Express. Ich mag es gar nicht glauben. Aber so ist es. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove. Wie immer führe ich durch die Sendung. Und jetzt sind schon wieder ein paar Wochen vergangen, seit der letzten und ich hatte mehrfach angekündigt, dass ich mir für diese Sendung was ganz Besonderes vorgenommen habe. Anders vielleicht als manche gedacht haben, feiere ich jetzt hier keine Internet-Chat-Party oder sonstigen Unsinn, sondern ich mache einfach so weiter, wie ich es bisher eigentlich immer gemacht habe und setze mir ein Thema. Aber ich wollte hier schon ein besonderes Thema ausgraben und ich dachte mir, was könnte es Interessanteres geben, als über das Internet als solches zu reden und möchte einen Rückblick wagen, einen Blick zurück in die Entstehungsgeschichte des Internets, ein Gefühl dafür vermitteln, wie denn das damals so war. Und wie es so üblich ist, bei Chaosradio Express mache ich das auch nicht alleine, sondern es gibt einen Gast und das ist zum zweiten Mal bei Chaosradio Express der Hans Hübner. Hallo Hans. Wir haben ja letztes Mal über Lisp gesprochen, was sich viele Leute angehört haben.
Ich bin erstaunt, dass das doch so viele interessiert hat.
Obwohl das so altes Zeug ist.
Ja, ich habe auch irgendwie so ein bisschen, also diese Sprache Lisp, um noch einen Satz dazu zu sagen, das ist halt irgendwie eine Sprache, die vom Cutting Edge von 89 kommt und dass die heute immer noch irgendwas bedeutet, das sagt schon was darüber aus, wie viel eigentlich passiert ist in den letzten 20 Jahren.
So 89?
Ja, aber Common Lisp, also das ist ja, ich meine, alles andere verdient den Namen ja nicht. Aber das ist schon interessant, dass so die Revolution der Computertechnik nicht passiert ist. Also das ist immer kleiner geworden und immer schneller, aber irgendwie ist es immer noch genauso schlecht und die Rechner sind unglaublich schnell, aber brauchen trotzdem immer noch Minuten, um zu booten und stürzen immer noch ab.
Das stimmt, die werden eigentlich immer langsamer.
Ja, das ist furchtbar. Das ist ganz furchtbar. Und man fragt sich ja, wie erzielen dann die ganze Zeit, die werden schneller und die Zahlen stimmen auch, wird schneller, aber trotzdem ist es immer langsamer. Das ist furchtbar.
Das ist wirklich grauenhaft. 1660 war damals sofort an.
Ja, sofort. Gut, also insofern ist natürlich diese Sendung und diese Geschichte auch so ein zweischnelliges Schwert. Man sagt irgendwie jetzt 20 Jahre und das Internet ist schon uralt und lalalala, aber genau genommen ist es halt eigentlich das gleiche wie schon vor 20 Jahren.
Wobei vor 20 Jahren, da gab es ja schon richtig Internet.
Na ja, nicht wirklich. Aber es hieß schon so. Das könnte man sicherlich debattieren, wann jetzt genau das Arpa-Internet in The Internet mit einem großen I umgetauft wurde. Denn eigentlich ist ja Internet nur die Bezeichnung für Netze, die Netze verbinden. Also eine...
Inter-Networks.
Genau. Inter-Networks.
Man nehme zwei Networks und schon hat man einen Internet-Hack.
So ist es. Und als das angefangen hat, da gab es schon Netze, aber die Netze, die waren eben lokaler Natur. So, man hat oder auch, also schon vielleicht mal eine Telefonleitung hier und da verwendet oder auch mal eine Standleitung hier und da verwendet. Aber genau genommen waren diese Netze abgeschlossene Sachen. Da gab es dann halt ein Netz für die Hochenergiefysik und ein Netz für, weiß ich nicht, die, jetzt fällt mir keins ein, für die gab es auch eins.
Jeder nur ein Netz.
Jeder nur ein Netz. Und Internet ist sozusagen das Konzept gewesen. Wir nehmen jetzt mal, wir machen jetzt mal was zwischen diesen verschiedenen Netzen. Und das ARPA-Internet war insofern da der Schlüssel zu der Entwicklung, weil diese Netze verschiedene Protokolle verwendet haben. Also es war nicht so, dass alle in ihren lokalen Netzen IP verwendet haben und es deswegen nur notwendig war, die Kabel miteinander zu verbinden, sondern jeder hatte da sein eigenes Netzwerkprotokoll. Also in der PC-Welt zum Beispiel war Novell ganz groß, da haben alle PC-Netze waren Novell basiert. Da konnte man dann zwar auch entfernte Standorte einbinden oder was auch immer, aber es war eben ein abgeschlossenes System an sich. Und damals gab es ja noch Minicomputer und Minicomputer kamen von verschiedenen Firmen und jede Firma hatte ihr eigenes Netzwerkssystem. DEC hatte DECnet und IBM hatte SNA und da gab es also verschiedene Architekturen, die grundsätzlich inkompatibel waren und wo es keine Möglichkeit gab, jetzt eine Verbindung herzustellen, die so funktioniert, wie man das heute kennt, dass man einfach ein Programm schreibt und dann auf einem anderen Rechner sich zu diesem Programm verbinden kann. Das gab es früher einfach nicht. Und das ARPANET hat insofern da den Weg bereitet, weil es eben eine von der US-Regierung bezahlte Entwicklung war, zunächst mal mit auch einem militärischen Hintergrund, aber das würde ich gar nicht so hoch aufhängen. Es ging darum, ein Netzwerkssystem zu schaffen, was paketorientiert ist und dem entsprechend ausfallsicher paketorientiert heißt, dass man nicht wie beim Telefon jemanden anruft und dann reinspricht und dann wieder die Leitung abbaut, sondern dass man ein Stückchen Daten irgendwo hinschickt und das Netz sich darum kümmert, dieses Paket an die richtige Stelle zu bringen. Und diese Entwicklung, die im Rahmen der ARPA gemacht wurde, die war zunächst mal auch proprietär, insofern, als es dann einen Rechner gab, den die speziell von BWN haben konstruieren lassen, der hieß EMP, Internet Message Processor, und davon haben die dann über Amerika eine Dutzend oder jedenfalls eine Handvoll verteilt. Die hatten alle Telefonleitungen miteinander und dann konnte man von einer Stelle in Amerika an eine andere Stelle in Amerika so paketweise Daten übermitteln.
So, jetzt mal ganz ruhig mit dem Pferd. Jetzt müssen wir erstmal ein paar Sachen, glaube ich, erklären. Also ARPA, nett, was du jetzt erwähnst, ist die Kurzform von Advanced Research Projects Agency und das ist eine Regierungsorganisation, kann man sagen, und zwar der US-Regierung natürlich. Das heißt, dort wurden, ich weiß gar nicht, was sie sonst noch so gemacht haben, aber ganz offensichtlich haben sie sich mit Advanced Zeug rumgeschlagen.
Und ja, fortgeschrittene Forschungsprojekte.
Genau, fortgeschrittene Forschungsprojekte. Und was war deiner Meinung nach der Grund, dass dieses Projekt so überhaupt geboren wurde? Es gibt ja zum Beispiel diesen immer wiederkehrenden Mythos, dass das Internet gebaut wurde, um Atomschlägen, Kommunikationen nach...
Ja, sicher. Also es ging darum, Netzwerktechnik zu erforschen, die fehlertolerant ist. Und Fehler sind zum Beispiel auch ausfallende Netzwerkknoten. Und wodurch das nur verursacht ist, das ist im zivilen und im militärischen Bereich, gibt es da unterschiedliche Szenarien. Aber grundsätzlich ging es darum, eine zuverlässige Netzwerktechnologie mal auszuprobieren und das mal auch zu deployen, also irgendwie mal zu installieren über eine große Fläche.
Also wir reden doch von den, ich meine, dieses Projekt ist geboren worden Ende der 60er Jahre. Also wir reden wirklich von, nicht, vorhin haben wir noch von 80ern geredet, wir sind noch mal 20 Jahre weiter zurück.
Naja, das war Ende der 60er Jahre.
Ende der 60er Jahre, 1969 haben sie das irgendwie das erste Mal realisiert. Da ist ja allein der Begriff Netzwerk schon was Besonderes gewesen, also von Internetzwerk mal gar nicht zu reden.
Kann man eigentlich so nicht sagen.
Dass man überhaupt genug Computer hatte, die zu vernetzen.
Nee, das kann man eigentlich so nicht sagen, denn das Vorläufernetzwerk, das Internet ist das Telefonenetz. Und das Telefonenetz hat es weltweit auch schon gegeben in den 60er Jahren. Da war das sicherlich noch nicht so wie heute, dass man von einem Funkgerät in der Pampa zu einem anderen Funkgerät in der Taiga eine Wehrverbindung herstellen konnte und da reinlabern. Aber internationale Wehrverbindungen gab es damals schon.
Na klar, aber da haben ja Menschen miteinander geredet und hier waren es ja Computer.
Ja, aber Computer haben eben über das Gleiche als auch miteinander geredet.
Okay, das war sozusagen das erste, was man herausgefunden hat. Gab es denn so viel Dial-up-Networking in den 60er Jahren?
Nein, in den 60er Jahren nicht. Naja, eben. Aber das gab es, weil das nämlich die einzige Möglichkeit war, mit den Computern überhaupt zu reden, es sei denn, man ist zu dem Computer hingelaufen. Es gab ja keine Computer in größerer Zahl und wenn es dann irgendeine Firma oder eine Universität oder eine Regierungsorganisation gab, die sowas hatte, dann war natürlich der Zugriff darauf schon eine Sache, ja, wenn man es brauchte, dann brauchte man es auch. Und dann gab es eben nur das Telefonnetz und dann hat man eben einen Akustikkoppler bekommen und konnte mit diesem Akustikkoppler sich dann einwählen in diesen Großrechnen. Also das ist nichts, was jetzt irgendwie, was sehr alt ist, sondern das ist eigentlich so alt wie der interaktive Zugriff auf Computer im Timesharing-Verfahren, so das gab es eigentlich schon immer. Was es nicht so viel gab in den Anfangszeiten waren, dass Computer miteinander geredet haben, so dass also zum Beispiel man eine Datei von einem Computer auf einen anderen Computer kopieren konnte, das war schon eher advanced, aber dieser interaktive Zugriff, dass man also Fernbedienung, Datenfernübertragung, hieß es ja im deutschen Fachjargon, das gab es schon sehr lange und das sind die Ursprünge von der Computer-Vernetzung.
Gut, also was hat jetzt das APA-Net, also APA-Net ist diese Gruppe von der US-Regierung und die haben dann vom Verteidigungsministerium irgendwie die Kohle bekommen und dann war irgendwie das MIT beteiligt und dann gab es so ein paar Jungs, die sollten halt einfach ein Netzwerk entwickeln, sag ich jetzt mal. Und dann haben sie da irgendwie fleißig geforscht und gebaut. Aber was haben sie denn dann gebaut?
Na zunächst mal haben sie einen Rechner gebaut, der mit anderen Rechnern verbunden werden konnte und der eine Adresse hatte und den man dann innerhalb dieses Verbundes adressieren konnte mit einer Nummer. Die fing dann erst mal bei 0 an und wurde dann hochgeziert bis 25 vielleicht so. Und dann konnte man halt an Knoten 6 eine E-Mail an Knoten 13 schicken und die kam dann auch an. Und das Netz hat dafür gesorgt, dass die zwischenliegenden Knoten alles richtig passiert hat und auch am Schluss gesagt wurde, ist jetzt angekommen und das alles automatisch dadurch geroutet wurde und zwar in Paketen. Und das war zunächst mal eine Sache, die nicht nur in Software bestanden hat, sondern eben auch in Hardware, weil man brauchte dann einen Rechner dafür, der erstens genug Speicher hatte, wo das Betriebssystem dafür ausgelegt war, solche Paketen nachrichten zu Routen, also sowas wie ein Router heutzutage, und wo eben genügend Leitungen dran waren, irgendwie vier oder sechs oder jedenfalls eine Handvoll Leitungen, die dann mit Modems verbunden wurden, mit irgendwelchen anderen Instanzen, genau dieser gleichen Hardware. Und die Leitungen, die dann zwischen diesen Rechnern aufgebaut waren, die, ich muss jetzt mal nachdenken, das weiß ich nicht, also jedenfalls, die waren nicht schnell, das Schnellste, was man so über Telefonleitungen in zu der Zeit machen konnte, waren 56 Kilobit in Amerika, 64 Kilobit in Europa oder im Rest der Welt. Aber die normalen Telefonleitungen haben eigentlich nur 9600 Bit pro Sekunde hergegeben. Das war so der Geschwindigkeitsbereich. Also als ich angefangen habe mit Datenfernübertragung, da waren 300 Bits pro Sekunde gängig, wenn man DFÜ gemacht hat. Das war 1984, also da waren 300 Bit pro Sekunde gängig und man hat auch schon von 1200 über normale Telefonleitungen gehört. Da musste man schon fortgeschrittene Modulationsverfahren verwenden und das ging auch nicht mehr mit einem Akustikkoppler, wo man nur den Telefonhörer reingedrückt hat, sondern musste man ein Modem haben, was richtig an die Telefonleitungen angeschlossen war. Aber es gab auch noch so Standleitungen, also wenn man sich eine spezielle Telefonleitung geschaltet hat, dann konnte man auch eine Standleitung bekommen, die 9600 Bit pro Sekunde oder auch 64 Kilobit gemacht hat, aber 64 Kilobit war also unglaublich schnell zu der Zeit. 64 Kilobit, boah, geil.
Das kriegt man ja nie voll.
Ja, das kriegt man nie voll. Boah, da sieht man ja gar nicht mehr, wie der Bildschirm sich aufbaut. Also diese Technologie, um über Telefonleitungen mit solchen Geschwindigkeiten, wie sie gerade nannte, Daten zu übertragen, das ist eigentlich Technologie, die in den frühen 70er Jahren entwickelt wurde und die dann nicht nur im APA-Netz, sondern auch in der Telekommunikationsbranche allgemein eingeführt wurde. Weil ja das Telefonnetz auch schon damals als das Vorläufernetz gesehen wurde und man schon erkannt hat, also auch alle haben das auch erkannt, naja Computer, das braucht man und wir wollen auch unsere Computer miteinander verbinden, haben sich auch die Telekommunikationsunternehmen, die damals meistens staatlich waren in den international besetzten Gremien, die dann eben auch von Staaten zusammengesetzt wurden, zusammengesetzt und Protokolle entwickelt, wie man international standardisiert Daten austauschen kann. Das ist die CCLTT-Protokollwelt gewesen. Die ist also auch aus den 70er Jahren, das ist also auch, sage ich mal, das ARPANET war sicherlich die ganz frühe Technologie, aber auch in den 70er Jahren ist dann die CCLTT dazu übergegangen, kommerziell nutzbare Protokolle zu entwickeln, die für solche Anwendungen geeignet sind. Und mit dem ARPANET ist es dann so weitergegangen, dass zunächst mal gab es diese hardwarebasierte Lösung, dann sind die ersten Protokolle...
Das ist das, was du erwähnt hast.
BBN Internet Message Processor, IMP.
BBN, das muss man glaube ich nochmal erklären, also BBN ist ja eine Firma, eine ganz besondere Firma in gewisser Hinsicht, weil die eigentlich so, ja, das Internet war, kann man sagen, oder? Für einen kurzen Moment. Also was war diese Box? Das war diese Hardware-Lösung, die du meintest, oder?
Das ist einfach ein Router gewesen. Die haben einen Router gebaut, hatten dafür den Auftrag, aus APA-Mitteln diesen Router zu bauen und haben die Hardware zufüllen gebaut, mit der die erste Internetinstanz, also die erste APA-Net-Instanz überhaupt so bestückt war. Aber das ist insofern keine besondere Firma, als dass die einfach den Zuschlag bekommen haben. Es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Firmen, die im Hochtechnologie-Sektor sind und die sich aus Regierungsaufträgen bedienen. Das ist da Gang und Gebe, genauso wie es so Luftfahrtfirmen gibt, die hier natürlich im Wesentlichen mit Militäraufträgen bestückt sind. Das ist ganz normaler Zulieferer. Das, was man jetzt als Internetprotokollwelt kennt, da findet man oft BBN-Mail-Adressen, aber da findet man auch MIT-Mail-Adressen und Mitre-Mail-Adressen. Berkeley hat dann auch irgendwann eine Rolle gespielt. Das ist schon diese Forschungsszene in Amerika, die teilweise staatlich ist, teilweise von den Unis besetzt wird und teilweise auch von den Firmen, die sich in diesem Dreieck bedienen bzw. da die Aufträge abnehmen.
Darauf wollte ich eigentlich auch hinaus. In Deutschland ist man es ja auch gewohnt, wenn hier so geforscht wird, da macht irgendjemand einen Topf klar und dann wird das so geforscht. Irgendeine Universität oder wer auch immer forscht dann so fünf Jahre und dann hat man geforscht und dann macht man wieder irgendwas anderes, so benutzen tut es wie keiner. Das wird jetzt vielleicht nicht allen Leuten gerecht, aber ich glaube, du weißt, was ich meine. Man hat nicht so den Eindruck, dass von der ganzen Forscherei so besonders viel hängen bleibt. Man ist ja dieses Apernets vielleicht jetzt auch so ein bisschen das Lichtbeispiel natürlich mit dem Internet. Trotzdem, es hatte eben dann auch relativ schnell einen konkreten Nutzen. Also es ist nicht nur so, dass man da jetzt so ein bisschen vor sich hin geforscht hat, wie wäre es denn mal, wenn wir mal Netzwerke hätten, sondern es kam ja dann auch tatsächlich schnell eben diese ganzen Forschungseinrichtungen an dieses Netz und haben das dann auch wirklich benutzt.
Na ja, also um da jetzt nochmal in diese Perspektive Ende der 80er-Jahre reinzugehen, da war das ja nicht so, dass das Internet eine Marktlücke gefüllt hat, sondern es gab Netze und die wurden auch im Forschungsbereich verwendet. Da hat jetzt niemand danach gerufen, dass irgendjemand mal ein Protokoll entwickeln möge, sondern das hauptsächlich in der universitären und Forschungswelt verwendete Netz war damals bit.net. bit.net war ein auf IBM Mainframes basierendes Store-and-Forward-System, wo man global E-Mails verschicken konnte und Files transferieren konnte und chatten konnte. Das waren tatsächlich so diese drei Anwendungen, die letztlich im Internet heute auch noch sehr, sehr wichtig sind, wenn nicht sogar dominierend. Also Chatten, Internet, Mails und Files. Und bit.net war deswegen auch sehr groß, weil ich glaube, die Software hat nichts gekostet und es gehörte zum guten Ton einer jeden Uni, auch am bit.net dran zu sein. Und jede Uni hatte auch einen IBM Mainframe. Das war also entweder ein Klon oder ein Original, aber das war so die beherrschende Architektur.
Aber das kam ja erst in den 80er Jahren auf.
Richtig.
Und du hast auch in den 70ern mit dem APA-Net, ich meine, da existierte es doch schon.
Da existierte das, aber da war das halt ein Forschungsnetz von Militärs.
Also, aber es waren doch auch Universitäten konkret angeschwossen.
Ja, da war irgendwie Lawrence Livermore dran und also diese Forschungsinstitute in den USA, die sich aus Regierungsaufträgen bedienen. Und da konnte, wenn man dann Atombomben gebaut hat, dann hat man halt auch einen Account bekommen, mit dem man aber nicht mehr verschicken konnte.
Ja, es war dann doch mehr das Loch in der Wand und nicht so, dass jetzt alle in den Rechnerraum reingekommen sind und es so eine glühende Kathedrale war. So, ah, hier ist das Internet.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Und vor allem, also zu der Zeit, als ich dann angefangen habe, und ich kann ja nur aus der Zeit berichten, weil da habe ich die Hands-on-Erfahrung, da gab es eine Community im Bitnet von wahrscheinlich so 10, 15, 20.000 Benutzern. So, und die waren halt global, das waren letztlich die Benutzer, die auf den IBMs die Accounts hatten. Und wenn man so einen Account hatte, dann konnte man da auch chatten und da gab es so einen Mail schicken, so vielleicht waren es auch 30 oder 40.000. Aber so in der Größenordnung, das war, was Networking und Netze in der Zeit bedeutet haben. Und zu der gleichen Zeit, als das Bitnet populär war, gab es noch andere Forschungsnetze. Was wir damals viel, wo wir viel Kontakt hatten, war HapNet. HapNet war ein DECnet-basiertes globales Netz von Hochenergie-Forschungseinrichtungen, die dann also so mit so Teilchenbeschleunigern und so Sachen gearbeitet haben. Da war das CERN eine der sehr wichtigen Einrichtungen, auch als Fahrschule der Hacker damals bekannt und auch jetzt in letzter Zeit wieder öfter so in der Presse gewesen. Also die hatten halt unglaublich viele große Rechner und die waren natürlich am HapNet ganz dick dran und dann hatten Leitungen überall hin, auch alle nicht schnell. So alles so im Bereich von 9600 bis 64 Kilobit, da konnte man jetzt nicht irgendwie Gigabytes durch die Gegend schaufeln. Das HapNet, das BitNet war ein IBM-basiert, das lief nur mit Mainframes, da gab es zwar auch irgendwelche, aber da gab es Freaks, aber im Prinzip war das ein Mainframe-Netz. Das HapNet war ein DECnet-basiertes Netz, also auf einem proprietären Netzwerkprotokoll von Digital Equipment aufgebaut, was eben auch dafür geeignet war, erstens mal so lokale Netze zu bauen und dann eben auch so Internets zu bauen, mit denen man einzelne lokale Netze zusammen schalten konnte. Man muss sich das ja auch so vorstellen, in den 70ern, da waren Computer einfach noch viel zu teuer. Und die Populationen von Leuten, die in der Lage waren, nicht nur mental zu begreifen, was da passiert, sondern da auch an der Konsole was zu bewirken, die war einfach sehr, sehr klein. Es gab zwar Freaks, aber...
Also es verwundert überhaupt nicht, dass so viele Physik-Laboratorien zum Beispiel da sind, weil die einfach schon immer viel Number-Crunching betrieben haben, schon zu damaligen Zeiten.
Genau, weil man auch als Physikerabstakt denken muss, das hilft da sicherlich auch bei, ne? Also das passt schon.
Das heißt, eigentlich waren so alle Atomforschungszentralen relativ früh an diesen Netzen dran.
Ja, kann man so sagen.
Das heißt, man muss sich das so vorstellen, man hatte weltweit eigentlich so führende Forschungszentren in den USA, aber auch in Europa und sicherlich auch in anderen Ländern. Wer war da noch so unterwegs zu der Zeit? Ich weiß nicht.
USA, Europa.
Japaner, nicht. Australien, nö.
Ja, also es gab natürlich hier und da und so, aber eine dichte Vernetzung hat es in Europa und USA gegeben, ansonsten war das jedenfalls separat und nicht sichtbar. Und für die asiatischen Länder war das eben einfach auch ein Problem mit dem Zeichensatz.
Ja, und die haben natürlich auch in der Regel alle auch noch nicht so den Entwicklungsstand gehabt wie heute. Ich meine, heute kommen die Computer alle aus China, damals kamen nichts aus China.
Außer Reis.
Und den haben sie dann meistens auch noch selber gegessen. Das ist auch das, was man sich fast gar nicht klar machen kann.
Also das war Europa, Europa, Nordamerika.
Okay, also wir haben diesen transatlantischen Pakt hier sozusagen am Start. Alle Forschungseinrichtungen sind untereinander verbunden und sie waren verbunden über Datenleitungen aller Art, unterschiedlich schnell, mit sehr unterschiedlichen Standards auch, auch wenn viele von diesen internationalen Standards, weil es ja eben meistens auch über Telefonnetz, Infrastruktur lief, definiert von der CCITT oder hieß es damals noch CCITT, ja genau heute besser bekannt als ITU und das waren eben diese ganzen Standards, die man heute so kennt mit dem X. Vor allem waren also natürlich allen voran, muss man hier erwähnen, X25, was halt schon insofern, also es gab ja so verschiedenste X, ich kenne sie gar nicht, X21 usw., die halt auch einfach nur so Computer zu Computerverbindung definiert haben. Aber der X25 Standard war insofern besonders, als dass er ja selber schon mal ein Datennetzwerk und auch noch ein, wie es so schön hieß, Paketvermittelendes Netzwerk beschrieb.
Ein Paketvermittelender Dienst, genau.
Den es auch in Deutschland gab unter dem Namen Datex P. Damit hast du dich auch ein bisschen beschäftigt.
Ja, also es war ja so, wie ich erwähnte, dass das Anrufen eines Computers gängige Praxis war. Man konnte also eigentlich in alle großen Computer, die es auf der Welt gab...
Bei wem war das gängige Praxis?
Na, in der Computeranwendung in den 80er Jahren. Da war das einfach gängig. Wenn man einen großen Computer hatte, dann hat man auch Modems gehabt, weil die waren dann zwar an geheimen Anschlüssen und hat man nicht unbedingt jetzt jedem gleich gesagt, wie die Nummer ist und so, aber schon für Fernwartungszwecke, weil es einfach zu wenig Spezialisten natürlich...
Die waren auch in der Regel an Telefonanschlüssen, an ganz normalen analogen Telefonanschlüssen.
Ganz genau.
Und nicht an speziellen Datenverbindungen.
Wie gesagt, je nachdem, was man für Sicherheitsanforderungen hatte, wenn man jetzt hohe Sicherheitsanforderungen hatte, wie zum Beispiel im Bankbereich oder so, da hat man sich eine feste Telefonleitung schalten lassen, aber es war eben trotzdem eine Telefonleitung, die über die gleiche Infrastruktur ging wie alles andere auch. Da vorne und hinten war ein Modem dran. Also eine Standleitung, wie man schon sagte. Genau, da wurden vorne und hinten Modem dran, wurden Töne drüber geschickt und fertig. So, das war gängige Praxis. Und das war auch in Berlin, als ich irgendwie aus der Schule kam oder noch zu meinen Schulzeiten, war das auch gängige Praxis. Zum Beispiel wurde unser Stundenplan in meinem Gymnasium, der wurde auf ein BS 2000-System von Siemens berechnet. Unser Physiklehrer war also auch zuständig für den Stundenplan und der hatte dann Zugang zu einer Maschine und da konnte er seine Lehrer eingeben und seinen Unterrichtsplan.
Hat er das selber programmiert?
Ich glaube nicht.
Also sind Sie wieder die Physiker?
Ja, aber jedenfalls war er als Physiker derjenige, der......
der prädestiniert war, den Stundenplan auszurechnen.
Genau.
Was ja eine ganz schöne Aufgabe ist, ne?
Ja, das ist nicht so einfach, manuell einen Stundenplan für eine große Schule zu bauen, macht schon richtig viel Arbeit.
Auf hat man sich wie das früher gemacht wurde, als es noch keine Computer gab?
Da gab es nicht so große Schulen. Ich glaube, eine große Schule geht auch wirklich nur mit einem Computer, weil man dann sonst den Stundenplan nicht geregelt kriegt. Wir hatten damals im Informatikunterricht Apple II-Rechner und einer von diesen Apple IIs hatte da irgendwie so einen Akustikkoppler dran und ein Akustikkoppler ist so ein Gerät, das die meisten werden es inzwischen auch mal gesehen haben. Aber solche Telefone gibt es ja heutzutage gar nicht mehr, die in ein Akustikkoppler reinpassen.
Das stimmt, damals waren die ja noch alle gleich.
Die Ikonik ist auch völlig gestorben von einem Telefon.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Wir reden von diesen alten Gurkentelefonen, die passten einfach wunderbar, die Hörer passten einfach wunderbar an den Akustikkoppler.
Und zwar interessanterweise weltweit. Also es war so, dass es einen weltweiten Quasi-Standard gab, wie groß so ein Telefonhörer ist und wie der geformt ist und welchen Winkel die beiden, die Hörer und die Sprechmöcher zueinander haben, sodass das eigentlich auch immer einigermaßen gepasst hat. Und da bei uns gab es dann eben einen schwedischen Akustikkoppler von Anderson Jacobson, da konnte man das Telefon, das daneben stand, reinstecken und dieses Telefon hatte zwar keinen vollständigen Amtszugang, aber man konnte eben in diesen BS 2000-Rechner von der FU Berlin reinwählen.
Warum konnte man das, also ich meine, warum hatte eure Schule so einen Modemzugang?
Weil der Physiklehrer die Stundenpläne halt auf der BS 2000 gerechnet hat.
Und der stand in der Uni. Na klar, und nicht in der Schule.
Entschuldigung, das habe ich eben ausgelassen. Wir haben den auch mal besichtigt, das war ein sehr großer und imposanter Rechner, mit vielen, vielen Festplatten, wo man zwischendurch laufen konnte. Also links eine Festplatte, rechts eine Festplatte, einen Schritt weiter, links eine Festplatte, links eine Festplatte. Das war imposant.
Da waren Festplatten noch so Geräte wie heute Waschmaschinen oder Trockner? Ja, durchaus.
So ungefähr so.
Auch mit der gleichen Wucht.
Ja, es gab da immer die Geschichte, wenn man im Rechenzentrum ging, haben sie immer die Geschichte erzählt. Ja, und damals im Rechenzentrum, da ist so eine Platte mal in Unwucht geraten und dann ist die Platte quer durchs Rechenzentrum geflogen und hat 15 Operator in Scheiben geschnitten. Naja, ich meine, es war eine andere Zeit schon, da hat dein Limiter wieder gefehlt.
Ja, das merke ich gerade. Dadurch muss ich ein bisschen mehr komprimieren, Hans.
Macht das. Ich meine, nur um das Setting da noch ein bisschen zu setzen, zu der Zeit war es durchaus noch üblich, wenn man irgendwelche Daten brauchte, dass man einen Operator-Request in seinem Rechner ausgelöst hat. Man hatte ja keinen eigenen Rechner, sondern Rechenzeit in der Uni. Operator-Request für Band 36 und dann ist der Operator losgelaufen im Rechenzentrum zum Schrank und hat das Band Nummer 36 geholt und hat das auf eins der verfügbaren Bandlaufwerke draufgelegt und also reingespannt und gestartet, gemountet und dann hat der Operator gesagt, jetzt ist dein Band gemountet auf Band Nummer 26 und dann hat man Zugriff auf dieses Bandlaufwerk gehabt und konnte sich die Daten davon runterkratzen. Das war also ein gemächlicherer Prozess. Das hat dann schon mal fünf Minuten gedauert, bis der das Band gebracht hat oder auch länger. Also das war das Setting und Datex P ist eben auch Ende der 80er-Jahre eingeführt worden als Paketvermittelender öffentlicher Dienst, der wurde damals von der Deutschen Post betrieben. Die Deutsche Post hat also ein deutschlandweites Netz aufgebaut, wo man seinen eigenen Rechner anschließen konnte für teures Geld mit zunächst maximal 9600 Bit pro Sekunde. Das war die schnellste Variante. Später kamen auch noch schnellere Anschlüsse, aber so schnell war das. Und sie haben Telefonzugänge zum Ortsnetztarif bundesweit angeboten. Das heißt, man musste nicht mehr, wenn man in Hamburg gerechnet hat, dann musste man nicht mehr das Ferngespräch nach Hamburg aufbauen, um da seine Terminal-Sitzung zu machen, sondern man konnte in den Datex-Pick-Noten in Berlin einwählen. Dort hat man sich dann angemeldet mit einer Benutzerkennung, die nannte sich NUI, Network User Identification. Und dann konnte man eine X25-Nummer eingeben. Und diese X25-Nummer wurde dann von dem Netz interpretiert. Und dann hat man eine Paketdatenverbindung zu dem Rechner beispielsweise in Hamburg herstellen können. Und das hat natürlich ganz neue Möglichkeiten eröffnet. Denn ich war damals auch Schüler. Und ich fand auch große Computer interessant. Und wollte auch ein bisschen mehr noch über die erfahren. Und es gab zwar in Berlin auch so die eine oder andere Nummer, die ich kannte. Aber erstens musste man ja dann auch immer noch einen Account haben, damit man reinkam. Und dann gab es in Berlin eigentlich nur Accounts für die Cyber. Und die Cyber war irgendwie nicht so spannend.
Die Cyber?
Ja, die Cyber von der FU. Also in der FU stand eine CDC-Cyber, 9600 oder so.
Kontrolldata.
Eine Kontrolldata-Cyber. Und das ist so ein Vektor-Rechner, wo man Fortran drauf programmieren kann. Man kann auch damit ein bisschen chatten. Aber irgendwie ist das ziemlich, also das ist nicht so…
Hat nicht gerockt.
Nee, hat nicht so richtig gerockt. Da musste man schon Fortran können und Fortran konnte ich nicht und wollte ich auch nicht lernen. Zumal meine erste Erfahrung mit solchen Rechnern war eben dann schon eine Vex gewesen. Nee, eine PDP 11. Und da konnte man in Belsik programmieren. Belsik konnte ich damals schon. Und da gab es auch einen freundlichen Command Prompt, mit dem man… der Help, hat der online Help. Da musste man nur Help eingeben und da kriegte man Informationen, was man jetzt alles tun konnte. Und dieses Selbst-Erforschen, das war natürlich großartig, weil ich natürlich keine Handbücher hatte. Vielleicht ist eine Cyber viel toller, aber sie hat sich halt nicht so erschlossen.
Ich muss nochmal kurz fragen, wo stand diese Vax?
Die erste Vax, auf der ich einen Account hatte, die stand in der TfH Berlin. Weil meine… also aus der Verwandtschaft hat jemand da studiert und die hatte eine Fortran-Aufgabe zu lösen und da hatte sie keinen Bock drauf und ich hatte aber Bock drauf und dann habe ich halt da auf der Vax ein bisschen rumgefummelt an dem Programm, bis das lief.
Da hast du aber noch selber davor gesessen, am Gerät.
Da bin ich ans Gerät gegangen, da bin ich in den Rechnerraum gegangen. Das war spaßig, aber da hatte ich keinen Modemzugang. Das Problem war, in Berlin gab es zwar ein paar Computer und es gab auch welche mit Modemzugang, aber die meisten waren halt nicht in Berlin und Datex P war sozusagen die Eröffnung immerhin erstmal von Deutschland als mögliches Erforschungsgebiet, wo man tolle Wechsel finden kann und es war eben so, dass Datex P auf X25 basiert und X25 ein internationaler Standard ist, kam es dann auch sehr schnell möglich, Internationalverbindungen herzustellen.
Muss man eine Sache nochmal erklären. Also wir haben ja schon gesagt, man kann sich einen X25, also man kann wahrscheinlich auch immer noch, sich einen X25 Anschluss nach Hause holen, aber das hattest du ja auch nicht.
Nein, man konnte sich einwählen, ich sagte es ja. Also der Trick war, dass man mit dem Pad, oder wie hieß das noch? Der Packet-Assembler, Disassembler, das ist im Prinzip das, was der Internet Message Prozessor auch macht. Auf der einen Seite spricht er dieses X25-Protokoll, hat also eine X25-Leitung und auf der anderen Seite sind ganz viele Modems dran. Und die Modems sprechen alle asynchrone Protokolle. Wo man tatsächlich eine feste Verbindung hat und einen Byte hinschicken kann. Und dann sieht das Gegensystem dieses Byte und kann irgendwas damit machen. Und wenn es jetzt ein Punkt ist, dann gibt es einen Punkt zurück oder kann erstmal warten, bis man Return drückt und dann ein ganzes Kommando interpretieren. Jedenfalls, das funktioniert mit einer Standleitung. Und diese Standleitung, also mit einer standstehenden Verbindung und diese stehende Verbindung von meinem eigenen Terminal zu dieser Gegenstelle, zu diesem Pad. Ja, jetzt habe ich einen Pfad verloren. Jedenfalls, der Pad ist da...
Ja, so griff man drauf zu. Ich versuche mir gerade... Ich erinnere mich noch an diese großartige Situation. Du hattest... Ich hatte dich damals in Berlin besucht, da habe ich ja noch nicht in Berlin gewohnt. Und du hattest ja auch noch diesen besonderen Bonus als Berliner, also als Westberliner, dass ja lokale Telefongespräche nichts gekostet haben.
Richtig.
Das ist ja etwas, was auch nicht mehr jetzt so in jedermanns Erinnerung ist. Also man hat nichts für Ortsgespräche zahlen müssen. Doch. Ja, aber nur einmal.
Also pro Anruf. 23 Pfennig pro Anruf.
Genau. Was kostet die deutsche Einheit? 23 Pfennig. Und dann hat man das einmal bezahlt und wenn man nicht wieder aufgelegt hat, dann hatte man halt einfach flat.
Das war schülervollendlich.
Das war schüler- und hackerfreundlich. Und ich weiß noch deine gesamte Installation. Also das war eigentlich, dein leeres Zimmer war einfach the future für mich, weil es bestand halt einfach so eine typische Hackerwohnung, die bestand im Wesentlichen einfach nur so ein paar rumfliegenden Manuals und einem Terminal, also einem ASCII Terminal, also einen Bildschirm, ein relativ kleiner Bildschirm auch für damalige Verhältnisse und eben so eine breite Tastatur. Und da hing dann dieses Modem dran und das war alles. Ja, also wirklich so Terminal, da hat man wirklich das Gefühl gehabt, da endet irgendetwas, also im wahrsten Wortsinne. Aber was du gemacht hast, ist, du hast dich quasi von dort in das Pad eingewählt, also eine ganz normale Rufnummer angerufen und dann wie auch mit diesen Computer-Mailboxen damals meldete man sich da eben an, wenn man den entsprechenden Zugang hatte. Und dann war man quasi im X25-Netz und damit war man in der Welt.
Genau, das ist also nicht anders, als wenn man heute einen ISP-Anruf sieht, der auch schon nicht mehr statt ist.
Das ist alles schon so ein bisschen vorbei. Also auch das war in den 90er Jahren Standard. Manche machen das sicherlich noch, aber die wenigsten.
Ja, und das ist ja auch so, wenn man heute den ISP-Anruf, dann ist man ja selbst mit seinem eigenen Rechner Teilnehmer in diesem Netz. Und das war halt damals mit den Pads und dem X-25 nicht so. Denn der Pad, der hat halt den Zugang liefert in das Netz. Und das letzte Gerät, was im X-25-Netz bekannt war, war nur dieser Pad und nicht etwa ich mit meinem Terminal. Das heißt, wenn ich irgendwie eine Verbindung hergestellt habe nach, weiß ich nicht, in die Schweiz, dann haben die Schweizer eine Meldung bekommen, da möchte jemand eine Verbindung herstellen und mit einer deutschen Nummer und die deutsche Nummer war dann aber die Nummer des Pads, nicht etwa meine Telefonnummer, was ganz gut war.
Man war so ein bisschen geheim.
Man hat sich so ein bisschen geheim gefühlt. Ich meine, es war ja auch damals so, dass diese 23 Fennich und der fehlende Ortstakt, der war natürlich ein Bonus, aber es war auch so, dass man das ganze Telefonnetz hätte erst mal erneuern müssen, was ja dann auch passiert ist nach der deutschen Einheit. Das war nämlich alles analog. Da gab es also noch Wählscheiben und Impulswahlverfahren. Also man konnte nicht etwa mit diesen Tönen wählen, was man heute so kennt, sondern es musste Impulswahlverfahren verwendet werden. Das kennt heute keiner mehr. Und diese ganze Technik, die dahinter stand, die war einfach uralt und rotten schlecht und da war es auch nicht möglich, mehr als 1200 Bit pro Sekunde durchzukriegen. Und für mich war es so, was halt teilweise Mist war, war, dass ich mir nichts ausdrucken konnte, aber dieses Terminal, das hat mir ja nur sozusagen den Rechner, mit dem ich gerade verbunden war, präsentiert und wenn ich irgendwelche Files hin und her kopiert habe, dann habe ich das auf dem Rechner gemacht, mit dem ich verbunden war und nicht mit dem Rechner, dem bei mir zuhause gestanden hat.
Cloud Computing. Cloud Computing, nennt man das heutzutage.
Ja, heute nennt man das Cloud Computing. Das ist ein ganz alter Traum auch schon gewesen. Es gab irgendwie in den späten 70er Jahren, gab es diese Vorstellung des Computing-Utility, das ist also genauso wie Strom und Wasser in den Haushalten eine Computeranschlussdose gibt, wo man Computerleistungen abrufen kann. Mit der Personalkomputer-Revolution ist das wieder alles eingegangen und jetzt haben die Leute alle schon mal eine creschende Festplatte gehabt und wollen jetzt Cloud-Computing haben, weil man nicht selbst ein Rechenzentrum betreiben möchte und auch nicht für Datensicherheit sorgen möchte und solche Sachen.
Das ist ja eigentlich auch jetzt passiert.
Jetzt hat man das ganze Internet, man hat die Internetdose zu Hause und da kommen dann die ganzen Dienste auch hereinspaziert.
Aber so richtig, dass sie überhaupt keine einzige Datei zu Hause speichern, das kommt jetzt so langsam, die Dienste und ähnlichen Kram, das ist schon so ein bisschen absurd. Natürlich war das damals alles sehr akkard, aber ich wollte jetzt auch nicht Ewigkeiten so auf so modernen Details rumhämmern, sondern was mich natürlich sehr viel mehr interessiert ist, was war so dein Eindruck, wie viele Leute damals eigentlich so wie du unterwegs waren?
Naja, also das ist ja immer schwierig zu sagen, wenn man... Man muss ja immer so eine Dunkelziffer im Blick haben. Und es gab so eine aktive Szene in den späten 80er Jahren von, ich würde mal sagen, so 100, 150 Leuten, die das in Deutschland gemacht haben und auch die darüber geredet haben oder zumindest bereit waren, sich ab und zu mal mit irgendjemandem anders zu treffen oder so. Vielmehr werden es nicht gewesen sein. Es gab sicher, es gab also die Dunkelziffer von Leuten, die sowas gemacht haben. Die besteht zum einen aus so Mailbox-Leuten, die sowas dann geheim gemacht haben, weil sie irgendwie Angst hatten oder weil sie Böses im Schilde geführt haben oder was auch immer. Da gibt es eine gewisse Dunkelziffer. Und die andere Dunkelziffer ist die von den Leuten, die in den Firmen gearbeitet haben, die solche Systeme gebaut haben oder entwickelt haben und die es halt nicht lassen konnten, aber die natürlich da sehr, sehr zurückhaltend waren. Da gibt es dann natürlich auch immer Überschneidungen in die eine oder die andere Richtung und es ist immer wieder mal vorgekommen, dass man jemanden getroffen hat oder dass ich jemanden getroffen habe, der aus einer komplett anderen Szene kam und mit der Computer-DFÜ-Hacker-Szene, die aus 150 Leuten bestand, überhaupt nichts zu tun hatte, aber total kompetent und Ahnung und wusste, was hier und wo, wie läuft es.
Die Ingenieure.
Ja, ja, die Ingenieure. Solche Leute gab es halt auch immer. Die meisten sind halt, ja, die meisten machen nichts, aber es gibt eben immer Freaks, die halt irgendwie dann abends auch nochmal ein bisschen müssen, weil es einfach so geil ist.
Das war jetzt so Europa, also das ist jetzt so Deutschland und so der Rest von Europa. War da Deutschland jetzt in irgendeiner Form Vorreiter oder waren da andere Länder auch in gleichem Maße aktiv? Was ist mit den USA?
Also in den USA ist die Situation da ein bisschen anders gewesen, weil das so eine Hacker-Subkultur, die so ein bisschen auch in der allgemeinen Subkultur auch mitverankert war und in den, sag ich mal hier so, MIT Computer Club und die Uni Freaks in Berkeley und so, das war so ein bisschen gesellschaftlicher eingebunden. Da kann ich also nicht unbedingt sagen, davon haben wir aber auch nichts mitbekommen. Die waren nicht im X25 unterwegs. So, die haben Telefon gemacht im Wesentlichen.
Und warum waren die nicht im X25 unterwegs?
Weil das in den USA keine Rolle gespielt hat. Es gab in den USA Gateways in die dort vorhandenen X25 Netze und in die dort vorhandenen privaten Netze wie CompuServe. Zum Beispiel CompuServe war ein sehr großes, US-weit operierendes privates Datennetz, was quasi sowas Ähnliches ist wie Google Mail heute, die haben halt Firmenaccounts auch verkauft. Das war der wichtigste E-Mail-Anbieter in den USA zu der Zeit. Aber so diese autonome Computerszene, die sich jetzt nur über die Technik definiert und über eine bestimmte Technik definiert, und da Sachen macht, die gab es glaube ich in den USA nicht so, sondern das ist immer so ein bisschen horizontaler gewesen. So jetzt mit Uni-Einbindung und irgendwie Studenten und solche Sachen. Die deutsche Hackerszene, in der ich mich damals bewegt habe, das waren halt wirklich Leute, für die war das so, das fanden wir toll. Wir sind hier die Elite und wir sind die einzigen weltweit. Und es gab ein paar Franzosen, wenige Handvoll, es gab ein paar Schweizer, in Italien gab es sehr sehr viele junge Leute, die in den X25 Netz rumgejuchtelt sind, aber die meisten waren irgendwie so Chatter. So Leute, die sich heute massenweise SMS schreiben würden, das waren die Italiener damals schon. Die sind immer in PULKS zu fünft oder sechst in die Chat-Systeme eingefallen. Damals war ein Chat-System groß, das waren dann normalerweise so 30 Regulars oder so. Plötzlich kam so ein PULK von Italienern vorbei, hat irgendwie auf Italienisch blablabla, da hat man versucht, denen klar zu machen, dass sie auf einen anderen Kanal gehen sollen, weil die weißt du, das sind auch keine englischen Sprachen, also außer einer oder zwei, da hat man die auf einen Seitenkanal geschoben und dann waren da die Italiener zugang. Also die waren eher so spaßorientiert, hatte ich das Gefühl, also da gab es nicht so einen technischen Austausch.
Also wir reden jetzt immer noch von einer Zeit, in der so etwas wie das Internet, wie wir es heute gewohnt sind, einfach nicht existierte, sondern die Computerinfrastruktur lebte im Wesentlichen an Forschungseinrichtungen oder vielleicht ein paar Universitäten und so etwas und nur, wenn man sozusagen sich dorthin begeben hat, konnte man eigentlich an der Party teilhaben. Und um sich dorthin zu begeben, wählte man zumindest in Deutschland oder sagen wir mal in Europa üblicherweise den Weg, dass man von seinem Rechner aus oder im Normalfall war es noch nicht mal ein Rechner, sondern eben einfach nur so ein Terminal, also nichts anderes als eine Tastatur und ein Bildschirm, was irgendwie Zeichen anzeigen kann und wenn man auf der Tastatur reintippt, dann wird das irgendwie über das Modem rausgeschickt, über dieses Pad in das X25-Netz rein. Aber um jetzt erstmal in das X25-Netz Zugang zu erhalten, musste man ja eigentlich auch Geld zahlen und das war ja nun auch nicht billig.
Richtig.
Und was musste man überhaupt tun, um in dieses X25-Netz reinzukommen und auf welche Art und Weise konnte man mit den Kosten dann auch klarkommen?
Also dieses X25-Netz ist ja grundsätzlich als kommerzielle bezahlte Kommunikationsdienstleistung geplant worden und die Abrechenbarkeit von Verbindungen war da reindesignt, was ja beim Internet nicht der Fall ist. Das Internet weiß überhaupt nichts von Kosten und Geld und wer zahlt und was auch immer. Im X25-Netz war das grundsätzlich anders. Und das Standardverfahren, was von der CCITT damals vorgeschlagen war, war eben diese Pads einzurichten. Und diese Pads liefern einem diesen Asynchron-zu-Synchron-Zugang, dass man also mit einem normalen Rechner und einem normalen Modem in das Synchrone X25-Netz reinkommt, aber gleichzeitig sind sie eben auch der Punkt, an dem abgerechnet wird. Man wählt sich also ein in diesen X25-Pad und dann muss man sich entweder mit einer Benutzerkennung anmelden und dann werden die Kosten auf diese Benutzerkennung abgerechnet oder man kann eine R-Nua anrufen, Nua heißt Network User Address.
Noch am ehesten vergleichbar mit einer IP-Adresse heutzutage?
Ja, vergleichbar mit einer IP-Adresse, genau, und man konnte einfach dieser IP-Adresse, dieser X25-Adresse, eine R vorstellen, wenn man es angerufen hat und dann wurden die Kosten auf die angerufene Stelle abgerechnet. Das heißt, die Kosten gingen dann auf denjenigen, den man angerufen hat.
Ein R-Gespräch, wie man so schön sagt.
Genau, also man merkt an vielen Stellen, dass diese X25-Protokollwelt eben aus der Telefontechnik kommt.
Das heißt, entweder man hatte eine NUI, die man selber bezahlt, dann wurde man alt oder man hatte eine NUI, die irgendjemand anderes bezahlt, die Firma oder irgendeine Firma?
Natürlich musste man wissen, dass es es gibt und dann musste man eine NUI haben oder eine Ernur, die gewillt war, einen reinzulassen und wo man dann auch wieder rauskam. Das ging ja auch. Also man hat, fangen wir mal mit dem Einfachen an, man hat eine NUI gebraucht und diese NUIs...
Das ist einfach User Password sozusagen?
Jetzt fällt mir gerade keine NUI mehr ein, aber eigentlich fällt mir und fand immer noch eine NUI ein. Jedenfalls waren das sechs Buchstaben und ein Passwort, das auch nur sechs Buchstaben hatte und das große Problem bei den NUIs war, dass man das Kennwort nicht selber ändern konnte. Das heißt, wenn man eine NUI hatte und das Kennwort irgendwie nicht ausreichend versteckt hat, dann hat man erst bei der Abrechnung gemerkt, dass da irgendwie ein Problem ist, wenn jemand sich die abgeguckt hat. Und das hat man auf der Abrechnung aber meistens auch sehr deutlich gesehen, weil das nämlich ziemlich teuer ist. Und es gibt Verbindungsgebühren und Pad-Nutzungsgebühren, also jedenfalls kamen immer substanzielle Summen zusammen, wenn mal eine NUI auf einer Messe verbrannt wurde. Der große Sport unter deutschen Hackern war, auf den Messen rumzulaufen und nach NUIs zu suchen, irgendwelche Stand-Fredis, die NUIs abzunehmen oder zu gucken, ob das in irgendwelchen Terminal-Funktionstasten abgespeichert ist oder solche Sachen. Und dann gab es halt diese Szene, in dieser Datex-P-Hacker-Szene, da wurden dann halt immer NUIs, die sprachen sich dann auch mal rum. Hast du eine Tante? Und wenn es mal eine keine NUI gab, dann hingen alle in irgendwelchen Chat-Systemen rum, hier bei Bitnet oder auf den Cybers oder so, und haben wieder rumgelungen, bis wieder irgendjemand eine gefunden hat und dann war wieder Party.
Und dann haben ganz viele dieselbe NUI benutzt. Und wie lange hat ihr so gehalten?
Na, es war sehr unterschiedlich. Je nachdem, wie viele Leute man am Spaß hat teilhaben lassen. Wir hatten teilweise welche, die viele Wochen liefen, wenn man dann aber Pech gehabt hat. Und einer war mal irgendwie unvorsichtig und hatte dann zu viele Leute weitergegeben. Dann ist halt doof. Und es kam halt auch immer darauf an, ob die NUI jetzt von einer großen Firma war, wo das irgendwie durchs Controlling durchfällt, ob man nur irgendwie 20 oder 30.000 DM an die Bundespost überweist. Das hat dann nicht so eine Rolle gespielt. Solche NUIs gab es auch, die dann eben sehr lange liefen. Aber oft waren es dann eben auch nur von irgendwelchen Journalisten. Oh man, wir waren nicht zu ein. Ne, wir waren nicht zu ein, ne, das stimmt.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt so eine NUI hatte, die gültig war, konnte man sich halt erstmal anwählen, am Pad und dann ging es überall hin. Das heißt, man startet dann mit einer NUA und dann gab es auch wiederum viele Listen, die rumgingen von Rechneradressen. Und das heißt, dass man im Prinzip dann eine direkte Terminalverbindung, so eine Tippverbindung hatte zu einem Computer.
Ja, im Prinzip das gleiche.
Und was war denn da so normalerweise, also was fand man normalerweise auf der anderen Seite so vor? Also kam dann gleich irgendwie Atomforschungszentrum, Tra-la-la, guten Tag, drücken sie hier die Taste, um die Missile zu starten?
Nee, also es war nicht üblich, sicherheitsrelevante Systeme mit dem X25-Netz zu verbinden. Also doch nicht? Nein, es war nicht üblich. Es soll eigentlich Fälle gegeben haben, wo es denn doch zu Lex gab, aber grundsätzlich war die, also ist es in Deutschland dieses Sicherheitsdenken schon damals verbreitet gewesen und es war also mitnichten so, dass da jetzt irgendjemand Rechner ins Netz gestellt hätte und gesagt hätte, hier, bitte, hier ist, weiß ich nicht, das Atomkraftwerk jülich und bitte logg dich ein und fahr Brennstreber hoch und runter, das ist natürlich totaler Quatsch. Die meisten Kisten, die man so im X25, wo man Zugriff drauf hatte, waren Maschinen von Leuten, die einen Computer brauchten, aber keine Zeit hatten, einen Systemadministrator zu bestellen, die dann aber irgendwie X25 brauchten und das da angeschlossen haben und dann hat das auch immer funktioniert und dann war alles gut. Solche Computer gab es im X25 viel, von irgendwelchen Zementfirmen oder von Bildschirmtextagenturen oder diese Forschungsinstitute, ganz viel, da ist es ja so, ein Professor beantragt Forschungsgeld, kriegt eine WEX genehmigt, kauft sich die WEX, steckt die da ran, dann muss die natürlich am Netz sein, X25 reingesteckt, ASSI hat sich ein bisschen im Manual umgetan und fertig. Und dann hatte das Ding eine NuA. Wenn der ASSI eine faule Sau war, was häufiger vorkam, dann konnte man sich damals einfach auch mit dem Usernamen Standard Password als System und Password Manager einloggen und dann hatte man die ganze WEX für sich, was man wollte. Das war das übliche Ding. Im Hochenergiephysiknetz war es so, dass die natürlich besser gewartet waren, aber dadurch, dass das weltweit war und die Leute sich viele E-Mails schickten, sind da auch viele Passwörter per E-Mail hin und her geschickt worden. So ist es dann doch immer wieder so gewesen, dass man irgendein unethischer Hacker eine E-Mail durchsucht und da das Passwort gefunden hat und zack, war das irgendwie durch. Und dieses Durchsuchen von E-Mails nach Passwörtern, das hat halt dazu gehört. Das ist natürlich unethisch, aber wenn man weiterkommen wollte, musste man halt daran.
Das heißt, es gab diese Nuas, zum Beispiel dann vom CERN, was ihr schon gesagt hast, so die Fahrschule. Fahrschule wahrscheinlich deshalb, weil da ganz viele Arten Nuas aufschliegen, schlugen?
Weil auf den CERN-Rechnern, da hatten halt hunderte von Wissenschaftlern Accounts und in hunderten anderen Rechnern hatten die ihre Accounts irgendwie ins Skripten oder weiß ich nicht, wenn die was auf die VX-CRNA kopiert haben, dann haben sie halt die Username, Passwort in das Skript reingeschrieben. Und die Kiste war aber schlecht gewartet. Du hast also diese Kiste aufgemacht, hast die Skripte durchgeguckt und hast festgestellt, aha, der Herr Professor Dietel Döö kopiert sich abends immer seine Files auf die CRNA und dann hatte man halt auch das Kissen.
Also im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Schweizer Käse.
Ja, kann man das sagen, wobei die dieses System-Manager am Zern natürlich sehr, sehr darunter gelitten haben und das gab dann also große Fights von Zern-System-Managern gegen die Hacker und die haben sich dann auch öffentlich geäußert und das waren sozusagen die Zern-System-Manager, das waren die schärfsten Hunde von.
Und wo kam denn diese Chat-Zerne, die du jetzt erwähnt hast? Ich meine, wurden die da sowieso schon betrieben oder wurden die dann von den Italiener dann aufgeschlagen?
Also die wahre Fahrschule der deutschen Hacker oder der X-25 Hacker aus meiner Zeit war die Firma Altos. Die Firma Altos hatte nämlich einen Unix-Rechner hergestellt und die hatten eine Filiale in München und in München in der Filiale gab es zwei Hacker, so im Sinne von, also nicht jetzt im Sinne von wie man das in Deutschland kennt, sondern eben so Computerfreaks.
Wie kennen wir denn das in Deutschland?
In Deutschland sind die Hacker immer die, die in fremde Rechner einbrechen.
Ich dachte, das wären die in den USA vor allem.
Und das musst du mal den Amerikanern erzählen, weißt du, was die dir erzählen? Ich meine, mein Job-Titel ist Hacker im Moment und glaubt man nicht, dass ich dafür bezahlt bin, in Rechner einzubrechen.
Es wandelt sich ein bisschen, habe ich den Eindruck. Es kommt wieder ein bisschen in Mode. An vielen Stellen ist es wieder möglich mit dem Begriff zu machen. Aber sind die definitiv zacken paranoider als in Deutschland, finde ich.
Die beiden Jungs, die bei der Firma Altos diesen Rechner betrieben und Hacker waren, die hatten halt...
Wie hieß denn dieser Rechner?
Also Firma Altos hat auch X25 Software betrieben. Die hatten halt, in der Firma waren die die Techs und haben halt eine Maschine gehabt und hatten auch einen X25 Hauptanschluss und dann hat irgendjemand ein Chatprogramm gehackt. Einer von den beiden nämlich. Und dieses Chatprogramm hat er dann halt im X25 erreichbar gehabt, das heißt, wenn man eine Nui hatte, dann konnte man sich da einfach hin verbinden und konnte chatten, so wie man jetzt überall heute auch chatten kann. Und das war für zwei Jahre lang so der Treffpunkt für diese Datex-P-Hacker-Szene. Also nicht nur…
Wir sind jetzt immer noch in diesem 84, 85, 86…
Das ist so 86, 87, 88, so was in der Größenordnung. Und Chats waren natürlich dann immer irgendwie lustig und ich hab dann auch mal ein Chatprogramm geschrieben, was dann auf irgendwelchen Wechseln lief, die wir irgendwo aufgemacht haben, das war, das fand ich immer sportlich, aber es war natürlich scheiße, Chats auf gehackten Kisten zu installieren, weil das dann doch irgendwann auffällt, wenn zu viele Leute…
Aber hast du nicht immer so den Ruf, ziemlich als Erster erstmal einen Chat aufzusetzen?
Ich möchte das nicht vollständig bestreiten, aber das nicht, dass ich in weit weniger Kisten als mir nachgesagt wurde, auch Chats installiert habe, aber ich hab's auch schon mal gemacht und vielleicht auch mal auf einer Maschine, wo irgendjemand anders gerade irgendwie sein ganz großes Ding drehen wollte, also mein Gott, ja, so, aber das mit den Chats war ein Dauerthema, weil Kommunikation ist halt irgendwie der Hauptteil des Spaßes, wenn man irgendwo im Netz unterwegs ist und dann triffst du irgendjemanden und kannst mit dem ein bisschen abschwatzen und dann geht's wieder weiter auf die nächste Kiste und wieder ein bisschen rummachen, so, das war eigentlich immer toll, so, das hat Spaß gemacht. Und es waren halt wirklich nicht viele Leute, es gab nur so einen überschaubaren Kreis von Leuten, die das überhaupt gemacht haben. Insofern war das schon...
Und man kannte sich bei seinem Nickname. Und daran erkannte man sich auch wieder. Das war dann so auch cool, oder?
Naja, mein Nickname war ja Pengo und nur aus der Not entstanden, weil ich irgendwie Computerspielsüchtig war, nämlich nach dem Spiel Pengo, was irgendwie Mitte der 80er Jahre...
Eine kleine Pinguine, die Eisblöcke.
Push, push und so weiter. Und dann habe ich bei... Also das erste Mal einen Akustikkoppler, der eine Mailbox angerufen hat, der mein Freund damals mir gesagt hat, ich soll mir jetzt einen Nicknamen ausdenken, und da ist mir nichts blödes eingefallen. Und da bin ich dann nicht nur zu diesem Nicknamen gekommen, sondern habe ich auch noch angefangen, Pinguine zu sammeln, und da ist mir dann von so auf den Keks gegangen, und dann kam dieses beschissene Pinguin-Metrißsystem runter und da hab ich gedacht, jetzt kannst du mich mit Pinguine echt nicht verraten.
Gut, also sprich, die Hacker haben dann sozusagen sich auch so ein bisschen ihre eigene Infrastruktur geschaffen, indirekt über diese Firmen, in denen sie gearbeitet haben, hier in Scheldt, hier in Starnschett und in zunehmendem Maße wurde das halt so benutzt. Aber was ist denn jetzt so, wenn wir jetzt diese Zeit beleuchten, da gab es ja auch noch andere Kommunikationsinfrastrukturen, die sozusagen das Internet auch teilweise mit eingeleitet haben. Also Deutschland war ja parallel zu diesem X25-Ding, was ja so ein bisschen noch unter dem Radar lief, war so mein Eindruck. Natürlich gab es da eine Szene, die war sich dessen vollständig bewusst, aber besonders sichtbar war das natürlich nicht.
Das war ja nicht Pop, sondern das war nur Business.
Also technisch war es nur Business, aber es hatte natürlich für die Leute, die da so drin waren, natürlich einen besonderen Appeal.
Ja, aber...
Diese Kommunikationsbedürfnisse waren natürlich...
Ja, das war einfach nichts, was normale Menschen irgendwie so hätten wahrnehmen können, weil man wirklich ein echtes Bedürfnis nach Computerleistung haben musste, um das überhaupt machen zu wollen, weil es unbequem, langsam, teuer und so weiter war. Und das war aber diese Mailbox-Netze zum Beispiel, die es zu der gleichen Zeit auch gab, die waren halt von Freaks gemacht und haben nichts gekostet und deswegen ist das groß geworden. Deswegen gab es dieses Fido-Net und in Deutschland gab es noch irgendwie drei oder vier andere große.
Maus-Net, Cerberus, und viele kleine Mailboxen, die einfach nur so für sich waren, die überhaupt nicht vernetzt waren.
Ja, da gab es irgendwie auch Mailboxen, die Vernetzung grundsätzlich abgelehnt haben und für schlecht. Aber da gab es dann halt eine kleine Benutzergruppe, die waren dann irgendwie kuschelig und warm und so.
Und die wollten nicht von außen?
Die wollten nicht irgendwelche, nee, ganz gar nicht, nee, ganz gar nicht.
Oh ja, ich erinnere mich auch, glaube ich, an eine. Trotzdem war das natürlich eine sehr lebendige Szene, wo natürlich auch viele Leute gestartet sind, die so überhaupt das erste Mal Kommunikation haben. Ich war gerade die ganze Zeit, was so bei mir so ein bisschen mein Mode im Erlebnis war, ich glaube, das fing auch mit so einer, mit der Computer-Mailbox an. Und interessanterweise war es natürlich auch der Chat, der einen überhaupt erstmal so gekickt hat.
Mit dem Sysop-Chatten.
Mit dem Sysop oder wenn es halt eine Mailbox war, die mehrere Leitungen hatte, das gab's dann Ende der 80er Jahre ja auch, also mehrere Telefonleitungen und eben finnige Leute, die diese Mailbox-Software geschrieben haben, die eben auch mit mehreren gleichzeitig umgehen konnten. Also ich glaube, bei uns in Hannover gab's eine Mailbox, da konnte man mit vier Leuten irgendwie drin sein gleichzeitig. Und das war natürlich schon ganz schön aufregend, weil man auf einmal so dieses textuelle Kommunikationserlebnis hatte, was ja sonst nicht, das gab's nicht. Man konnte Leute anrufen, es gab keine SMS, man konnte vielleicht Leuten auf einen Anrufbeantworter sprechen, das war dann aber auch schon das höchste der Gefühle. So, aber weder war E-Mail noch in irgendeiner Form, also das gab's zwar natürlich dort auch, aber in der Regel halt so, dass man seine Nachricht auf der Mailbox halt so schrieb und dann darauf warten musste, dass diese andere Person sich dort angemeldet hat, um sie dort zu lesen.
Ja, dort angerufen hat, man musste ja die Mailbox auch anrufen, das haben manche Leute dann halt auch nur einmal pro Woche gemacht und so. Aber dieses Chatten, das fand ich ja von Anfang an toll, bloß man konnte halt immer nur mit dem Sysop chatten. Und CallSysop war sozusagen eine der Standardfunktionen aller Mailboxen. Und die Multi-User-Mailboxen, das war der ganz große Traum, als wir damit anfingen, aber da waren halt 64, C64s waren aktuell und da ist mit Multi-User einfach mal Essig. Also ich meine, heutzutage findet man genug C64-Programmierer, die talentiert genug wären, eine Multi-User-Mailbox auf einem C64 zu implementieren. Das war damals nicht der Fall, also das ging einfach nicht.
Das stimmt, das musste ja auch erst mal alles erfunden und entdeckt werden. Auf der anderen Seite gab es ja auch, vor allem in den USA, auch noch so eine User-Bewegung, die mit dem Internet ja ganz gut verheiratet wurde später, nämlich das Usenet. Hast du damals davon was mitbekommen?
Ja, natürlich. Weil das Usenet war das Offline-Netz, was wir damals so benutzt haben. Usenet ist ein News-System, in dem es zu verschiedenen Themenbereichen Newsgroups gibt. Das sind einfach sowas wie Bretter, oder wie man das heute nennt, so wie es wie Foren. Und das Usenet basierte auf der UUCP-Protokollimplementation. Unix hat an dieser ganzen Entwicklung einen relativ großen Anteil. Und UUCP und Usenet ist eben ein unmittelbar aus Unix hervorgegangenes Netzwerk, eine aus Unix hervorgehende Netzwerktechnik. Man konnte relativ schnell und relativ einfach in einem beliebigen Unix-System ein Programm konfigurieren, mit dem man auf ein anderes Unix-System Dateien überspielen konnte und Programme ausführen konnte.
Eben das UUCP, also Unix to Unix Copy sozusagen.
Und das war offline, das heißt, das funktionierte so, dass man einen Job für einen anderen Rechner angelegt hat, oder auch mehrere, und dann wurde entweder automatisch zeitgesteuert oder manuell eine Verbindung über einen Telefonmode mit diesem anderen Rechner hergestellt und diese Jobs alle nacheinander abgearbeitet. Und das Ergebnis wurde dann per Mail wieder zugeschickt, wenn da irgendwas schief gegangen ist oder so. Weiterhin war es so, dass man nur auf diesem benachbarten Rechner einen Job starten konnte. Zum Beispiel schickte man eine Mail an Rolf auf diesem anderen Rechner. Und was dann dazu entwickelt wurde, wurden so Programme, die auch so eine Store-and-Forward-Mechanik konnten. Das heißt, ich konnte an meinen Nachbarrechner eine Mail für jemanden schicken, der mit diesem Nachbarrechner nur indirekt oder auch direkt verbunden ist, aber jedenfalls über mehrere Schritte hinweg. Aber eben alles offline und alles über Telefonleitungen. Und das Usenet, dieses News-Protokoll, das funktioniert eben so, dass man sich an einer oder mehreren dieser News-Groups anmelden konnte als UCP-Teilnehmer. Und dann alles, was in dieser Gruppe neu gekommen ist, immer mit so einem UCP-Job zugespielt bekommen hat. Das heißt, man hat einmal pro Nacht eine Verbindung aufgebaut, dann hat man alles, was an neuen Nachrichten in dieser Gruppe gekommen ist, eben rüber kopiert bekommen.
Aber da musste man natürlich auch irgendwo das herholen.
Ja, aber erstens gab es dieses UCP-Netz weltweit und es gab große UCP-Knotenpunkte, die mit sehr, sehr vielen Rechnern, mit sehr, sehr vielen anderen Rechnern verbunden waren. Und dieses ganze Netz war selbst organisiert. Also das war jetzt nicht ein Netz, das von einer Firma organisiert war und auch kein Netz, das von einer Forschungseinrichtung betrieben wurde oder was auch immer, sondern es hat wirklich nur davon gelebt, dass sich irgendwie zwei Unix-Heinis zusammengesetzt haben und ihr UCP miteinander aufgesetzt haben. Und dann hat sich das von selbst quasi entwickelt. Es gab dann in den USA auch so Leute, die richtig Geld hatten und die sich dann große Rechner gekauft hatten, mit denen sie viele, viele UCP-Verbindungen abkonten. Pyramid hatte so einen riesigen Rechner, das war glaube ich sogar von Pyramid selber. UUnet war so eine Firma, die sich quasi nur dafür entwickelt hat, wobei diese ganzen UCP-Knoten, die waren eigentlich alle angefangen als irgendein Assi an der Uni oder ein System-Manager oder irgendjemand privat hat halt damit angefangen. Und das hat sich dann meistens so von selbst entwickelt. Das hat damals so funktioniert, dass da so Maps ausgetauscht wurden. Das weltweite UCP hatte jetzt keine zentrale Adressliste, in die man sich eingetragen hat, sondern es gab so Maps und man hat einfach Maps miteinander ausgetauscht, in denen drin stand, mit wem man noch so alles spricht. Also wir hatten irgendwie dann noch zwei andere Knotenpunkte, die mit unserem Rechner verbunden waren. Dann haben wir in unsere Map reingeschrieben, dass der und der mit uns täglich redet. Und diesen Map-Eintrag, den findet man übrigens noch im Internet. Ganz lustig so. Diese Map-Einträge, die hat man dann eben auch in so einer Newsgroup, in so einer Usenet-Newsgroup einfach verteilt und sich die dann abgegriffen und sich daraus dann so eine Routing-Tabelle zusammengebaut, sodass man nicht mehr den Pfad von über Hans Horst, Ulf, Rolf, Bla nach Jüjünet mailen konnte, was man auch konnte, was auch gängige Praxis war, sondern dass man eben einfach an Rolf, Jüjünet schreiben konnte und dann hat der Rechner...
Das war sozusagen die Geburtsstunde des Ad.
Das war die Geburtsstunde des Ad, genau. Also die ersten UACP-Mailer, die kannten diese Ad-Notation noch nicht, die kamen nämlich dann erst mit dem ARPANET, weil das ARPANET halt eine zentrale Adressliste, eine zentrale Rechnerliste gepflegt hat und nicht so wie das UACP dezentral organisiert war. Der eigentliche erste Adressstandard, mit dem ich groß geworden bin, war die BANG-Notation, wo man eben Hostname, Hostname, Hostname, Username geschrieben hat und das alles jeweils mit einem Ausruhungszeichen voneinander getrennt hat.
Der BANG-Pass.
Ja, es gab eine Zeit lang quasi auch noch üblich so eine Prozent-Notation zu haben, dass man also statt, dass man auch manuell routen konnte mit Ad-Adressen, das war alles ganz furchtbar. Und dieses Sendmail zu konfigurieren, das war alles so grauenhaft.
Ja, ich könnte mich da auch noch ganz gut dran erinnern.
Das war unglaublich schlecht. Aber letztlich hat das UECP die Anwendungsschicht des Internets gebildet. Es war nämlich so, dass dann also Unix hat auch insofern eine entscheidende Bedeutung für die Entwicklung des Internet, weil der TCPIP-Protokoll-Stack, der für das Berkeley Unix entwickelt wurde, weil der open source war und irgendwie Mitte, Ende der 80er Jahre kostenlos verbreitet wurde und dadurch als Keimzelle für die Implementation des Internet-Protokolls...
Das krasse ist aber ein bisschen voraus, weil das hat ja mit dem Usenet so nichts zu tun. Also diese Anwendungsschicht, du redest ja davon, dass man sozusagen das Mail-Kommunikation normal wurde und dass vor allem diese spezielle News-Kommunikation normal wurde, die man heutzutage eher so als schwarze Bretter oder Foren vielleicht wiederfindet. Komischerweise ist ja... also News, das kann man glaube ich heute gar nicht mehr ermessen, wie unfassbar populär dieser Dienst war. Das war einfach die Methode, öffentlich zu kommunizieren im Internet. Da gab es kein Web, so selbst E-Mail war nicht auch nur im Ansatz so.
Melanüsse schon, ja. Aber News war der Broadcast-Dienst.
Genau, weil man konnte sich einfach ein Themenforum heraussuchen, was halt so hierarchisch gegliedert war und da ging es dann irgendwie ab. Ich wollte über Unix reden, komp.os.unix und da waren dann aber auch wirklich alle, oder? Also alle, die Unix gemacht haben, haben da gelesen und vielleicht auch geschrieben. So alle im Sinne von jeder, also jeder auf diesem ganzen fucking Planeten, der sich mit Unix beschäftigt hat, las das. Sowas gibt es heute einfach gar nicht mehr, solche Orte. Und ja, wie du schon sagst, das war so diese Anwendungsschicht, das ist das, was das Usenet an der Stelle geschafft hat. So und das basierte auf Unix und jetzt können wir auch gerne noch mal drauf zu euch kommen. Bis dahin war ja dieses ganze Internet, gab es ja so noch gar nicht. Wir hatten jetzt irgendwie das APA-Net und wir hatten jetzt viele andere Netze, Bitnet, tralala, man konnte mit X25 unterwegs sein, das waren alles lose gekoppelte Dienste. Wie hat es denn eigentlich dieses APA-Net geschafft, an all dem sich vorbeizudrängeln und zu dem Internet zu werden, das wir heute kennen? Also wer hat denn gesagt, das ist es?
Nein, das hat sich von selbst ergeben.
Und das hat sich ergeben dadurch, dass BSD, Unix sozusagen mit Open Source kam.
Richtig, das hat sich dadurch ergeben, dass das mit Unix, auf der Unix-Plattform eine signifikante User-Basis war, mit dem Usenet und die UCP als Protokoll und E-Mail, funktionierender E-Mail.
Das waren vor allem Sun-Rechner?
Ja, Sun-Rechner, weil da gab es viele Hersteller.
Aber Sun war natürlich extrem populär, insbesondere an den Universitäten damals.
Ja, aber es gab wirklich viele verschiedene Unix-Hersteller. Es gab viele verschiedene Unixe und viele verschiedene Hersteller, HP und DEC und Compaq, natürlich nicht, Apollo und viele kleine Firmen, die ihr eigenes Unix gemacht haben. Das war eine populäre Sache. Aber ich glaube, der ganz wesentliche Punkt war, dass es eine echte User-Basis gab für dieses Usenet und für dieses Mailsystem. Leute, die das gar nicht wussten, wie das funktioniert, die das einfach nur benutzt haben. Das hat dann dazu geführt, dass als das TCPIP-Netzwerkprotokoll entwickelt wurde und auf Basis von Unix entwickelt wurde und dann auch auf Basis von Unix frei verfügbar war, dass dann plötzlich ein Fortgeschritt in das Netzwerkprotokoll zur Verfügung stand, das sich auch dafür geeignet hat, diese User-Basis mitzubenehmen.
Wer hat denn das entwickelt? War das noch bei APA?
Das ist aus APA-Mitteln in Berkeley entwickelt worden. Ich glaube, das ist eine kalifornische Entwicklung. Es war zumindest so, dass das Berkeley Unix das System war, wo das IP-Protokoll fortentwickelt war. Das war das hackerfreundlichste Protokoll, das war am leichtesten zugriffbar. Das hackerfreundlichste System war am leichtesten zugriffbar. Es gab zwar auch IP für die Großrechner-Systeme, aber da konnte man halt nicht so dran rumhacken. Gerade bei der Protokollentwicklung von Netzwerkssoftware, da muss man halt auch die Maschine mal crashen können und so weiter. Insofern war das schon notwendig, dass es zugreifbar ist und es auch möglich war, da eine eigene Hardware für die Entwicklung von Netzwerkprotokoll-Features zu haben. Dieser IP-Protokoll-Stack, der jetzt quasi die Basis von allem im Internet darstellt, natürlich auch inzwischen noch neu implementiert wurde und so weiter, aber der hat dazu geführt, dass plötzlich ein Netzwerkprotokoll zur Verfügung stand mit einer Implementation, mit der auch verschiedene Rechner verschiedener Hersteller miteinander sprechen konnten und das war eben in der Zeit durchaus nicht selbstverständlich. Es gab alle möglichen Netzwerkprotokolle von allen möglichen Herstellern, die waren teilweise noch nicht mal mit sich selbst kompatibel und geschweige denn mit Dingen, die die anderen gemacht haben und dann gab es eben das Usenet und die Usenet-Protokoll-Familie, die dann sehr schnell auch im IP, also über IP übertragbar waren, wo man dann plötzlich Mails verschicken konnte und das hat funktioniert und zwar zwischen einem PC und MS-DOS, zwar mit Handständen und so weiter, aber es ging, und einer Wechsel oder so und das war neu. Das war schon eine Revolution, das gab es so vorher nicht, das gab es zwar so Gateways, aber das war alles immer ziemlicher Rotz.
Wer hat denn dann dem Internet eigentlich seinen finalen Namen verpasst? Weil es hieß ja nicht von Anfang an so, sondern es war ja eigentlich eher das Arpa-Net.
Das Arpa-Internet, das Arpa-Net ist, also wenn man jetzt da, also ich meine, da können sich dann irgendwann die Geschichtforscher drüber einigen, was wie genau heißt, aber das Arpa-Net an sich, das sind die Rechner gewesen, die von DARPA gesponsort an diesem ersten Netz angeschlossen waren, was rein intern war für amerikanische Forschungseinrichtungen, wo man von außen eigentlich nicht so wirklich dran kam, sondern die hatten erstmal nur Forschungscharakter. Und das Arpa-Internet war dann das auf dem IP-Protokoll basierende Quasi-Meter-Netz, mit dem diese Netze untereinander verbunden wurden. Das erste Internet, das erste Arpa-Internet hatte auch Netzwerknummern von 0 bis 255. Also das ist noch einfach eine ganz andere Technologie gewesen.
Und dann hat man es auf vier Bytes erweitert und dachte sich, boah, das kriegt man ja nie voll. Die alte Illusion.
Ja, ich meine, es ist so, dass ein wirkliches Charakteristikum dieser ganzen Netzwerkprotokoll-Welt und dieses ganze Internet ist, dass es eben einfach ungeplant wächst und ungeplant auch entsteht und nicht dadurch, dass man sich hinsetzt und sich überlegt, was macht wirklich Sinn. Es war ja so, dass das X25-Protokoll nicht alleine dasteht, sondern Teil einer Protokollfamilie war die vom CCITT mit Regierungsgeldern und über lange Zeit und mit schlauen Leuten entwickelt wurde. Ein Teil dieser ganzen Protokollfamilie ist auch ein E-Mail-System, was schon im 84er Standard irgendwie grafische Übertragung von Grafikdaten spezifiziert hat und wo Verschlüsselung mit im Standard festgeschrieben war und Directory Lookup, wo man irgendwie nach Namen suchen kann in Firmen oder in Staaten oder was auch immer. Und das sind alles Sachen, die waren damals halt viel zu früh und das Internet hat es zwar schlecht gemacht, aber es gab User, die wollten das so haben und die haben geglaubt, dass es irgendwie richtig ist, eine URL mit http:// hinzuschreiben und haben das so beigebracht bekommen und da sind diese ganzen Protokolle, die eigentlich verfügbar waren, die sind darunter dann eigentlich eingegangen. Und letztlich ist das das beste Beispiel für schlechter ist besser.
Ja, es gibt nur noch so hier und da so Überbleibsel. Also das ArpaNet kann man heute noch irgendwie sehen, wenn so ein Lookup gemacht wird, also nicht vom Namen zu einer IP-Adresse, sondern umgekehrt, dann endet das ja dann auf Punkt Arpa und diese toten Protokolle, also hier so LDAP ist ja noch so ein fernes Überleben von dem X599-Ansatz, der Directory-Lookup, den du angesprochen hast. Also hier und da hat man es dann noch verheiratet und auch so dieses OSI-Schichtenmodell, darauf hast du dich wahrscheinlich vor allem drauf bezogen, wie hieß es noch gleich, das Netzwerkprotokoll, was sie dann darauf basiert haben, also die reale Implementierung. Jetzt, oh Gott, die Vergangenheit entschwindet auch langsam, mein Hirn, wie auch immer.
Ja, da gab es sogar Leute, die das entwickelt haben, bloß diese Standards waren erstens dick, das war teuer und drinnen schlecht geschrieben. Und wenn man in den üblichen RFC-Reihen guckt, dann liest man den auf dem Klo durch, während man ausscheidet und danach glaubt man, man hat Netzwerktechnik verstanden. So ist viel von dieser Software entstanden. Es gibt halt den Genius-by-Accident, dass irgendwelche Leute es trotzdem richtig machen, obwohl sie es eigentlich nicht verstanden haben. Aber es ist eben nicht sehr wissenschaftlich, der Ansatz.
Ja, der praktische Hackeransatz hat sich letztendlich durchgesetzt mit dem Internet. Kann man schon so sagen. Ich bin mir gar nicht so ganz so sicher, weil mir der Begriff als Seucher das erste Mal so über den Weg gelaufen ist, also gerade in Deutschland dauert ja dann noch ein paar Jahre. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die Trends, so wie heute, so nur noch fünf Minuten brauchen bis in unsere Zeitung, sondern damals hat es ja teilweise Jahre gedauert, bis man dann wirklich mal irgendwas davon mitbekommen hat. So war es mit dem Usenet, so war es halt auch mit dem Internet als Seuchen. Irgendwann schlug das Internet dann mal in Holland auf, in Amsterdam, wo auch heute noch der größte Netzknoten ist, das Amsics. Da kam dann das erste Mal dann amerikanisches IP an und es hat dann auch noch ewig gedauert, bis das wirklich so seinen Weg gefunden hat, bis nach Deutschland. Aber zu Hause wirklich IP-Connectivity zu haben, davon konnte man also lange Zeit nur träumen. Das wurde dann halt erst Mitte der 90er Jahre wirklich Realität. Ja, jetzt sind wir so weit abgeschweift, was ja auch okay ist. Ich würde ganz gerne noch mal so ein bisschen zu dieser frühen Hackerfahrschule, wie man sie auch immer nennt, zurückkommen, wo man sich jetzt so traf. Was war denn das so für ein Gefühl, wenn man da so unterwegs war?
Ich glaube, dass das eigentlich gar nicht so unterschiedlich ist von dem Gefühl, wenn man heute im Internet in irgendeinem speziellen Film unterwegs ist, also in irgendeinem spezielles soziales Umfeld im Internet hat.
Na gut, aber heute kann man irgendwie zu seinen Freunden gehen und sagen, ich hab ne Stunde im Internet verbracht und die sagen, ach ja, hab ich auch grad gemacht.
Ja, also für mich hat das letztlich bedeutet, dass ich mich von meinem sozialen Umfeld, was ich so normalerweise gepflegt hab, schon massiv entfernt habe. Und ich merk das heute, wenn ich also heute Leute treffe, mit denen ich zur Schule gegangen bin oder so, dann hängen die noch irgendwie mit den gleichen Leuten rum und sehen sich noch öfter mal und so und also ich glaube, dass ich das deswegen auch nicht mehr mit denen rumhänge, weil ich mich eben damals auch in der Zeit, wo man viel mit Leuten rumhängt und solche Bindungen eingeht, von denen habe ich mich einfach entfernt. Ich meine, ich hab halt irgendwie nächtelang am Rechner rumgehangen und mit Leuten abgehangen, die die komisch fanden.
Na gut, aber das ist ja nicht so rechnerspezifisch. Ich meine, man kann ja auch in seiner Schulklasse so ein bisschen das Black Kid sein und dann geht man halt irgendwie auf die Groovy Parties und nicht auf die Pop-Schnurzel-Veranstaltungen, wo die anderen hingehen und hat dann eine ähnliche Distanz oder Nähe. Das ist irgendwie nicht das, was ich meine, sondern dieses, man trifft sich im Chat. Ich meine, wir haben mal so eine Chaosradio-Sendung gemacht, Ende 2007, ich glaube 130 war das so, Living the Future, wo wir so geredet haben über diese Momente, wo man so das Gefühl hat, oh Scheiße, jetzt ist Zukunft irgendwie, gerade die Tür aufgegangen und die Zukunft lacht mir einfach mitten ins Gesicht, was weiß ich, das erste Mal ein Handy im Wald und solche Momente. Und das, ich meine, so Anfang der 80er oder vielleicht Mitte der 80er der Jahre, irgendwie in Schweizer Computern rumzuchatten, das ist ja nochmal plus plus. Naja, das hat doch irgendwie alles um zehn Jahre vorweggenommen.
Ja, ich meine, ich bin jetzt einfach da 20 Jahre von weg und irgendwo ist da für mich auch der Punkt erreicht, wo ich das nicht mehr so aufregend finde.
Ich hab ja auch gefragt, wie du dich damals gefühlt hast.
Es ist sehr schwierig zu sagen. Natürlich haben wir uns damals gefühlt wie die Elite der Elite, weil es außer uns niemanden gab, der das gemacht hat, was wir gemacht haben. Ganz offensichtlich so. Und natürlich haben wir uns besonders gefühlt. Jeder weiß, dass es für seine Zeit zwar was Besonderes war, aber letztlich auch wieder nur irgendwelche Spinner, die in Computern rumgehackt haben. Insofern ist es für mich jetzt ein bisschen schwierig, das Gefühl zu beschreiben, was ich damals hatte, weil dazu habe ich darüber einfach schon zu viel nachgedacht und mir da irgendwie eine Meinung zu gemacht und auch ein Verhältnis dazu, was jetzt nicht mehr nur von Glorifizierung der alten Zeit geprägt ist. Aber eine Sache kann ich ja erzählen, die für mich sehr prägend und aufregend war und mich deswegen auch noch, wo ich mich auch heute noch daran erinnern kann, das war nämlich so, ich war eben in diesen Hochenergiephysiknetzen sehr viel unterwegs und habe mir immer die Nächte um die Ohren geschlagen, um in irgendwelchen Wechseln darum zu hacken und irgendwie Programme geschrieben, die sich dann von selbst kopieren konnten und halt irgendwelche Manuals ausgedruckt und gelesen und gemacht und getan und irgendwie habe ich mir halt ständig die Zeit in Wechseln vertrieben und einmal war es so, dass ich dann in einer Wechsel im Caltech in Kalifornien rumgehangen habe und da so irgendwie Mainz gemacht habe und irgendwie rumgebastelt habe und dann chattete mich jemand an und das war der Sysop von da, also der Systemmanager und Ich bin der Hackerfahrschulen, der hat mich angefohnt. Das gab so ein Programm Phone, das war noch ein bisschen anders als Chat heute, weil man bei Phone die Tastendrücke des Gegenübers sofort gesehen hat. Also es gab so zwei Fenster oben unten, oben kamen seine Tasten, unten kamen meine Tasten.
So wie Talk unter Unix auch.
So wie Talk unter Unix ja. Also Talk war immer so ein unglaublich schlechter Abklatsch von Phone. Okay, ich hab's dich erwähnt. Bitte.
Okay, Caltech, California Institute of Technology.
Jedenfalls fohnte mich der Sysop an und dann haben wir so ein kleines Gespräch geführt, weil er sich also ganz offensichtlich dafür interessiert hat und der hat mir dann halt so beschrieben, wie er das jetzt gerade auf die Bay guckt und die Sonne geht jetzt gerade auf und bei mir war es irgendwie spät in der Nacht oder umgekehrt. Jedenfalls war die Zeitverschwiebung sehr deutlich und das war schon ein ganz kurioser Moment, weil wir uns dann halt so unterhalten haben und ich den wirklich nicht kannte und der aber natürlich einer von der anderen Seite war, weil ich war halt irgendwie Hacker aus Deutschland und hatte in dem Rechner in CalTechnics verloren und der war Systemmanager und seine Aufgabe war sicherlich eigentlich mich zu verhindern, zumindest war es ihm sicherlich nicht recht und dann hat er halt behauptet, ich könne ja wohl bei ihm auch nicht wirklich Systemprivilegien haben, was ich ihm dann auch zeigen musste, dass es doch so ist, dass ich Systemprivilegien habe und so. Also das war so eine interessante Unterhaltung. Ich hab dann später, der Typ, der mich damals angetalkt hat, der wurde dann irgendwie zu einem der wichtigen VMS-Gurus und war dann noch lange weiter, aber das war so eine Sache, das war für mich so ein toller Moment. Das war noch bevor die ersten großen Hacker-Stories kamen und so. Das war lustig und der wollte halt, ich meine, ich hab dem dann auch gesagt, ich bin aus Deutschland und lalalala und hier und Hacker und Fasseldröhnen und so und ja, erzähl mal, was macht ihr so? War echt lustig.
Da in Kalifornien haben sie irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, so die deutsche Hackerfront war dann schon so eine spezielle Geschichte, wenn im Wesentlichen jetzt alle so über das X25 herangetrabt kamen und besonders die gut ausgebaute deutsche Telekommunikationsinfrastruktur, die Leute beflügelt hat, da unterwegs zu sein, war das dann im Wesentlichen so die deutschen Hacker in Europa, die dann irgendwie in großen Mengen zur Verfügung stehenden Rechner in Amerika betreten haben, wenn man jetzt mal vom CERN abseht? War das so die Besuchsstruktur, die typische?
Das kann man, also ich tue mir echt schwer, über Amerika irgendwas zu sagen in der Zeit, weil das eine wirklich andere…
Ja, aber ich meine, wo habt ihr euch denn im Wesentlichen rumgetrieben, wenn ihr nicht im CERN wart? Wo waren denn diese Rechner, die man sich vor allem anschauen wollte?
Naja, letztlich war es uns ja egal, solange es… also mir war es völlig egal, wo der Rechner stand, solange es eben der Wechs war.
Ja gut, aber wo standen die Wechs?
Na ja, die standen…
Die standen doch wohl sehr häufig auch in den USA.
Die standen auch in den USA, ja. Also ich persönlich, mein ganz persönlicher Ansatz bei der ganzen USA-Geschichte war der, dass ich vor den Amis schon relativ viel Angst hatte, weil ich irgendwie, also ich bin ja in Westberlin aufgewachsen und Westberlin war irgendwie pazifistisch und ich komme auch aus pazifistischen Kreisen, also ich hatte mit dem Militär nichts zu tun und das Einzige, was ich an Militär kannte, waren die Amerikaner, die mit Jeeps durch Westberlin gefahren sind, mit Maschinengewehr hinten drauf und Helm und uns angeguckt haben. Für mich waren Amerikaner nicht mehr die Retter, da bin ich aus einer anderen Generation. Für mich waren das die, die mit Waffen herumgelaufen sind und das haben wir nicht gemacht, das war bei uns nicht gängig. Und deswegen hatte ich vor den Amis eigentlich immer relativ viel Angst. Ich meine, in dem Hapnetz hat es sich so ergeben, dass man auch mal amerikanische Kisten gehackt hat, aber prinzipiell war das für mich nicht so attraktiv, das war mir irgendwie unheimlich. Ich fand das irgendwie besser bei den Italienern oder in Australien oder so in der Schweiz. Das war irgendwie überschaubar, damit bin ich besser klargekommen, aber die Amis haben mir immer irgendwie ein bisschen Angst gemacht. Ich war auch paranoid.
Aber vielleicht nicht paranoid genug.
Ach, ich meine, ich glaube, mein Teil an Paranoia habe ich irgendwie abgearbeitet. Aber ich glaube eben, dass ist eine amerikanische Hacker-Szene, dass die amerikanische Hacker-Szene sich nicht so unmittelbar gegen diese X-25-Szene, das kann man nicht so unmittelbar vergleichen. Weil da in Amerika war es so, dass sich dieses Telefonproblem nicht so ergeben hat. Weil die Amerikaner dieses beschlossene Telefonnetz mit den Tönen hatten, wo man sich irgendwie frei Telefongespräche machen konnte. Und dadurch war es in Amerika schon lange nicht so sehr das Problem, dass man an irgendein Rechner irgendwo rankommt, weil die waren alle am Netz. Und natürlich konnte man kostenlos telefonieren, so in Hackerkreisen. Insofern war diese ganze Problemlage eine andere. Und diese X25-Netze gab es in Amerika gar nicht. Also es gab zwar, wie gesagt, diese Zugänge, damit man aus Europa da rein konnte, aber innerhalb Amerika war Telefonleitung angesagt.
Das heißt, da waren auch genauso viele amerikanische Hacker unterwegs?
Ja, aber da gab es keine, also ich habe nie jemanden getroffen.
Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Das verstehe ich auch nicht. Das kann ich dir so nicht sagen.
Haben die irgendwas anders gemacht? Waren die an anderen Sachen interessiert?
Ich glaube, die haben sich einfach auch in anderen Foren und in anderen Gegenden herumgetrieben. Oder vielleicht haben die auch nichts gemacht. Es kann ja auch sein, dass die Amis keinen Arsch in der Hose haben. Das möchte ich jetzt so gar nicht sagen. Oder es kann auch so sein, dass die meisten Amis an den tollen Unis so schnell da integriert waren in die Szenerie und da Zugriff auf die Rechner hatten und so weiter, dass das nicht so ein Problem war wie für mich persönlich. Für mich persönlich war das Problem, ich konnte einfach...
Es gab einfach den Exzess.
Ja, vielleicht war das ganze Problem da anders gelagert. Also es gab ja diese Hacker-Szene und die Kongresse und Treffen mit den anderen und so. Und da war der Austausch mit amerikanischen Hackern, der ging dann meistens eher auf diplomatischer Ebene und weniger auf der operativen Ebene. Also so. Dass man mal einen amerikanischen Hacker getroffen hätte, der irgendwie coole Sachen macht, die man auch gerade macht, das ist mir sehr selten passiert. Ich glaube eigentlich sogar nie. Jedenfalls kann ich mich jetzt nicht daran erinnern.
Das heißt, die hat man eigentlich eher über die Softwareentwicklung kennengelernt?
Ja oder eben Usenet oder einfach so auf persönlicher Ebene mit diesem Caltech-Sysop bin ich ja nicht warm geworden in dem Sinne, weil der wollte ja sich mit mir messen. Aber ich kannte mal jemanden am MIT, mit dem waren wir einfach so befreundet. Also so auf persönlicher Ebene ja, aber eben nicht auf der operativen Ebene, was auch irgendwo –die Geschichte der europäischen Hacker ist ja auch ein bisschen so anti-amerikanisch. Die Szene, in der ich mich bewegt habe, die hat nicht unbedingt Freundschaft geschlossen mit dem offiziellen Amerika unmittelbar oder so, sondern da gab es ja doch dann relativ viel Ärger und Nerv.
Ja, in dem Zusammenhang will ich dann doch noch mal die unsägliche Geschichte ansprechen, die sich natürlich jetzt automatisch ins Bild schiebt. Also ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das am besten angehen soll. Also du warst ja damals so mit anderen Kumpels unterwegs, aber ich weiß nicht genau, wie du das so sehen würdest. Und habt euch beschwarzen lassen, eure technischen Dienstleistungen sozusagen als Auftragsarbeit umzusetzen. Kann man das so formulieren?
Ja, das kann man so formulieren, da bin ich jetzt nicht beleidigt.
Und wie kam es dazu?
Also ich wollte eine VEX haben.
Du wolltest nicht immer nur...
Ich sag's, wie es ist, ich wollte eine VEX haben. Und ich wollte eine VEX haben mit einem X25-Anschluss in Ostberlin. Und dann hätt ich Bock gehabt, auch ein bisschen weiter zu hacken.
Du wolltest eine VEX haben in Ostberlin?
Ja klar.
Weil man da nicht so gut zurück zu verfolgen ist.
Das hab ich ja so an mich herangekommt. Ich hatte vor den Armiens echt eine Schweineangst. Die Osis wollten aber nicht bezahlen. Und dann war ich da auch relativ schnell raus aus der Geschichte. Das mag jetzt irgendwie doof klingen, aber so war meine Überlegung. Ich hatte tierischen Bock irgendwie, Wechseln, Wechseln, Wechseln, Wechseln. Fand ich total geil. Und ich hatte auch total Bock drauf irgendwie auf Wechseln, krasse Root-Kits, sagt man ja heute, zu schreiben, mit denen man irgendwie so machen kann. Das hat mich irgendwie gezackt, das fand ich toll. Und dann habe ich irgendwie versucht, irgendwie an den Wechsel zu kommen. Und es ging aber nicht. Und dann habe ich halt irgendwie im Internet, also im Netz, Internet sagt man heute, rumgehackt und auf irgendwelchen Kisten rumgehackt. Aber das ist immer elend, weil dann probierst du irgendwas aus und dann kackt die Kiste ab und dann ist der Betreiber sauer und dann holt er den Service und dann sperren sie einen aus. Und all diese ganzen Sachen, die wollte ich halt nicht haben. Und dann gab es halt diese Diskussion mit den angeblich Russen, die irgendwie was haben wollten. Und dazu habe ich dann irgendwie gesagt, naja, ich möchte das machen, wechseln interessiert mich. Wenn ich wechseln machen kann, dann ist das vielleicht auch für die Russen so. Da hatte ich jetzt nicht so eine Probleme mit.
Du hast aber nicht gleich den Weltumsturz sozusagen im Sinn gehabt, und das eine System ging, das andere System auszuspielen.
Ach naja, ich meine, ich bin da, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht bin ich da doch dann realist genug zu sagen, also ich glaube das nicht. Ich hatte einfach nur Bock auf Rechner haben. Ich war einfach nur geil drauf.
Kann ich nachvollziehen, das heißt dann auch alles irgendwie, alles bestimmt.
Das war halt so damals das Ding. Und diese ganze Geschichte ist ja dann weitergegangen, viele haben den Film gesehen. Dieser Kontakt zu den Russen, wer auch immer das jetzt genau im Detail war, weiß ja auch keiner, da ging es darum, dass die eigentlich Embargo-Software kaufen wollten, um nichts weiter ging es. Und Embargo-Software, also es war halt zu Ost-West-Zeiten war es so, dass man halt bestimmte Software nicht nach innen in den Ostblock liefern durfte und schon gar keinen Quellcode und deswegen gab es eine Bestellliste von Quellcode, den die halt im Osten brauchten, weil sie irgendwelche Sachen machen wollten oder irgendwie den Compiler reparieren mussten oder es hieß mich tot, die brauchten halt irgendwelche Sachen und die Sachen, die wollten sie dann halt gerne von uns kaufen und da gab es dann Preislisten und dann gab es auch Leute, die sind da rangekommen. Aber du hast es ja voll in beschrieben, das war gar nicht mein Metier. Ich hatte zu Hause einen Terminal und ein Modem und da konnte ich keine Software klauen. Das war überhaupt gar nicht möglich.
Stimmt, weil wo hin sollst du sie runterladen, weil es ja noch nicht mal ein Computer hat.
Es gab tatsächlich und ich habe tatsächlich mal auf irgendeinem Computer irgendwelche Daten auf irgendein Band gespielt, auf einem Server, was dann auf irgendwelchen Umwegen an mich gelangt ist. Da war irgendwas mit drauf und das habe ich dann mitgeschickt. Das sollen sich die Russen mal angucken, kam aber nichts bei raus. Und also, naja, da wurde dann irgendwie ein Riesenfass aufgemacht und natürlich ist es auch falsch so, ich habe mich da auch in Gefahr begeben und so.
Also wir müssen noch kurz erklären für diejenigen, die jetzt nur ein Fragezeichen im Kopf haben. Also wir reden von diesem Fall, der halt bekannt geworden ist, als der KGB-Hack, ja, sehr groß aufgehängte Geschichte. Auch sehr tragisch, weil ja nun einer dieser fünf, die dort aktiv waren, der Karl, der Karl Koch, halt später ums Leben gekommen ist und da, ja, bis heute eigentlich weitgehend unklaren Umständen. Offensichtlich ein Selbstmord als Ende einer Psychoreise, die er durchgemacht hat über längere Zeit.
Ja, also ich meine, mit den ungeklärten Umständen, das würde ich einfach mal ganz klar verneinen. Das ist nicht ungeklärt, sondern das ist für mich einfach klar. Und ich finde, was du sagst, ist gut, das ist eben das Ende einer Psychoreise gewesen. Und ich bin da auf eine gewisse Art und Weise natürlich, habe ich damit so meinen Weg gefunden, damit umzugehen und hatte auch meine Motivation, das damals zu tun. Und bei Karl war das eben eine Station auf einer Reise, durch sein Leben, die einfach ganz schön schlimm geendet hat. Und das war schon eine sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr schlimme Sache. Aber diese ganzen Geschichten mit Psychiatrie, die da abgelaufen sind und mit Drogen, also LSD und Kokain und solche Sachen, das ist das, was für mich dabei wesentlicher ist, als diese KGB-Geschichte. Diese KGB-Geschichte war nur so ein unglaublicher Beschleuniger, weil wir waren die Einzigen auf der Welt. Natürlich haben wir da gesessen und wir sind die Einzigen auf der Welt, die hier von Berlin aus in die Schweiz und dann nach Amerika und gleich nach Australien. Natürlich haben wir uns toll gefühlt. Und je nachdem, wer welche Drogen genommen hat, geht dann natürlich so ein Kopfuniversum auf, was nicht unbedingt beherrschbar ist. Wo man nicht unbedingt von vornherein sagen kann, wo endet das. Da gibt es eben diese Kopfkomponente und dann gibt es die externe Komponente. Ich glaube aber, dass diese externe Komponente, also was mit Geheimdiensten abgelaufen ist, wie der Prozess abgelaufen ist, wie das von den Amerikanern behandelt wurde, da haben wir natürlich kein vollständiges Bild. Aber das ist auch nicht so, dass da jetzt Märchen erzählt werden und dass es alles ganz anders war, sondern ich war insofern schon ein paar mal dabei, um so ungefähr einschätzen zu können, in welcher Situation sich Karl selber befunden hat, wie ansprechbar der war, welche psychischen Schwierigkeiten der gehabt hat und auf der anderen Seite eben auch in was für ein Mindset wir waren, als wir in den Rechnern herumgehackt haben und als wir mit irgendwie ohne Passierschein in die DDR gereist sind und da uns mit Agenten getroffen haben. Das war natürlich aufregend, natürlich.
Klar, das wüsste ich gar nicht, was in der damaligen Zeit noch hätte sehr viel aufregender sein können als das.
Letztlich war diese Geschichte auch das Weiterdenken und die Konsequenz dessen, wir sind hier die Einzigen, die das können und vielleicht sind wir halt diejenigen, die die Weltrevolution herbeiführen können oder was auch immer. So realistisch oder unrealistisch, wie man das jetzt sehen muss, war das halt irgendwie so damals, als wir Anfang 20 solche Sachen gemacht haben, war das eben dann unser Leben.
Aber letzten Endes sind da nicht wirklich Daten generiert worden.
Was meinst du Daten generiert worden?
Naja, was sie haben wollten, also diese Cocon-Listen oder so.
Es gab ein paar Sachen, die verkauft wurden, da wurde irgendwie Unix-Sourcecode verkauft und irgendwelche Compiler-Sourcen und so Zeugs, was nicht jetzt gehackt wurde, sondern dann gab es dann halt Firmen im Umfeld und die hatten das und dann wurde das halt mal skupiert und mitgenommen und hat halt 5000 gebracht. Das ist passiert und das ist auch gerichtskundig geworden und die Leute, die das gemacht haben, die sind dafür auch verurteilt worden. Also insofern war das auch eine realistische Sache und nicht nur irgendwie ein Fall der nationalen Sicherheit, sondern da sind eben einfach wirklich Dinge kopiert und weitergegeben worden.
Aber jetzt nichts, was irgendwie den Ausgang des nächsten Weltkrieges maßgeblich hätte beeinflussen können?
Also ich meine, ich habe ja auch nicht jetzt so viel in militärischen Sachen rumgehackt, weil ich einfach ein Schisser bin. Und mir war Amerika sowieso unheimlich und amerikanisches Militär war mir noch unheimlicher. Da gibt es aber gleich noch einen interessanten Twist, weil man manchmal ja nicht weiß, wo man drin rummacht. Aber dass wir irgendwie in militärische Systeme oder in Systeme, bei denen wir erkennen konnten, dass es sich um geheime oder sicherheitsrelevante Bereiche handelt, dass wir da reingekommen wären, das ist mir nicht passiert. Also zufällig passiert einem das nicht. Und ich glaube, dass es auch sehr schwierig ist, zu unterstellen, dass man als Hacker nur ausgehend von der Technik in der Lage sein soll, plötzlich das, was hinter der Technik steht, überhaupt rauszufinden oder zu finden. Wenn ich irgendwie in ein Atomkraftwerk, was versehentlich mit X25 verbunden ist, reinkomme, dann wird da ja nicht drinstehen Atomkraftwerk, sondern dann wird da drinstehen irgendwie Prozessrechner-Tilidro. Und dann müsste ich erstmal mit der Prozessrechner-Software mich so weit auseinandersetzen, dass ich plötzlich erkenne, hier geht ja was schief. Also diese ganzen Fantasien von wegen, ja, sicherheitsrelevant und da kommen wir überall rein und Hacker können die Welt beherrschen. Das halte ich alles für ausgemachten Schwachsinn, das ist Quatsch. Also solche Dinge gehen nur mit Insider-Wissen, nur wenn man außerhalb dessen, was man im Rechner sehen kann, Informationen besitzt, dann kann man überhaupt mit dem Rechner etwas anfangen. Aber eine ganz interessante Geschichte dazu ist, dass wir in den späten 80er Jahren irgendwann bei Cement Francaise rumgemacht haben. Und das hat die Franzosen, also Cement Francaise ist eine französische Zementfabrik. Und da haben wir uns überhaupt nichts beigedacht, da hatten wir ein Dutzend Wechseln, die waren über ganz Frankreich verteilt und hatten viel Spaß. Das fanden wir überhaupt nicht schlimm und auch überhaupt nicht aufregend oder irgendwie spannend, aber die Franzosen hat das irrsinnig erboßt. Weil wer braucht denn viel Zement? Die brauchen die für ihre Silos und ein Bunker und so weiter. Da haben die richtig Stress gehabt mit und wir haben da einfach so, naja, so tolle Webse. So läuft das. Ich glaube, dass... Ich meine, es gab diese Informationssysteme des US-Militärs, es gab den Mitre-Switch, wo man sich reinwählen konnte und da konnte man eins von 15 Systemen auswählen und eins der Systeme hatte irgendwie Stellangebote für Hacker, aber immer US-Citizenship required, das war irgendwie schon...
Eure Tätigkeit kommt mir so ein bisschen vor, so ein bisschen wie heute, wenn so Kids irgendwie rumziehen und irgendwie ihr Graffiti überall draufballern und sich auch nicht unbedingt jetzt immer so viel Gedanken darüber machen, ob das jetzt so eine kluge Aktion ist gerade oder nicht.
Ja, also das hat irgendwie natürlich allen anscheinend davon und das war auch so. Ich meine wir haben uns dafür toll gehalten und wir wissen wie gut wir, wie einzigartig und genial wir sind und dann habe ich irgendwann, nachdem dieser Prozess in dem KGB-Dings da abgelaufen ist, habe ich mal einen Gutachten gesehen, wo ein Gutachter vom IABG, von so einer Firma, die hier für die Bundesregierung Gutachten schreibt, bewertet hat, wie wir so drauf sind und der hat halt geschrieben, naja die sind da auf Studentenniveau, auf zwei, drittsemesterniveau sind die da vorgegangen und so war das auch. Also da war sehr viel, sehr viel irgendwie, wir sitzen in der Kammer und rauchen haschisch und treffen niemand anders, deswegen sind wir die größten Gedankengut auch dabei.
Im Kontext dieser KGB-Geschichte gab es ja auch diesen recht bekannt gewordenen Fall mit diesem, was war er eigentlich, amerikanischer Physiker, dieser Clifford Stoll, der ja, dem sozusagen Hackeraktivitäten in sein Rechnersystem aufgefallen sind und dann mit einem erhöhten Aufwand herausgefunden hat, dass die Spur nach Deutschland zeigt und darüber dann eben auch Aufhebens gemacht hat.
Das war der Auslöser für die Ermittlungen letztlich.
Wie lief denn das?
Na ja, also die Legende von Clifford Stoll sagt, dass er irgendwie da einen Studentenjob gehabt hat, die Abrechnung zu machen für den Rechner und dass da irgendwie ein Fehler für einen Rechner in Berkeley an der Uni war.
Also Abrechnung der Systemzeit.
Genau, der Systemzeit. Und dann hat er da einen Skript geschrieben, mit dem er die Systemzeit abrechnet, wahrscheinlich, um jemanden das in die Rechnung zu stellen oder was auch immer, was ihn dazu motiviert hat. Jedenfalls hat er da eine Diskrepanz festgestellt, dass das Abrechnungsprogramm irgendwelche Zeiten nicht berechnet hat. Oder was nicht gefunden hat. Irgendwie gab es da einen Fehler. Und diesem Fehler ist er dann, so sagt die Legende, nachgegangen und dabei dann auf deutsche Hacker gestoßen, die bei ihm ein System rumgemacht haben und die vor allem sein System benutzt haben, um von da aus wieder übers Telefon in andere Rechner in Amerika reinzuhacken. Und seine Geschichte geht eigentlich dann so, dass er dann da nicht nachgelassen hat, bis er die ganze Geschichte bis nach Deutschland, bis nach Hannover verfolgt hatte. Und da bin ich heutzutage immer noch nicht von überzeugt, dass das, was er da in dem Buch schreibt. Dass das alles so viel von der wahren Geschichte erzählt. Also allein diese Abrechnungsdiskrepanz, das war bestimmt nicht so, sondern er hat ihn bestimmt einfach gesehen, dass er da irgendwie eingeloggt war. Und dass er dann irgendwie daran beteiligt war, dass die Polizei letztlich eine Hausdurchsuchung hier veranlasst hat und er da zu den Infos bekommen hat und so. Das sind alles so Sachen, da gebe ich nicht so viel drauf, muss ich sagen. Ich glaube, dass Clifford Stoll ein Bewusstsein mit seinem Buch geschaffen hat für die Problematik. Und dass das Buch dafür geschrieben wurde, so eine Geschichte zu erzählen, die von vorne bis hinten vorne anfängt und hinten aufhört und so. Aber wie viel das mit der Realität zu tun hat, ich weiß es einfach nicht. Da habe ich nicht so viel Vertrauen, glaube ich.
Trotzdem hat diese Recherche, die dort ausgelöst wurde, insofern bemerkenswert war, dass ja dann wirklich auch deutsche Behörden aktiv wurden in Deutschland. Ich weiß nicht, ob es dann noch zahlreiche Fangschaltungen gab, die da noch mitbeauftragt wurden. Da frage ich mich natürlich, wodurch überhaupt diese Dringlichkeit so klar gemacht werden konnte.
Sicherlich nicht, weil irgendein Hippie mit Bart in Berkley 20 Cent in der Abrechnung fallen sollte.
Das ist das, was ich mich immer gefragt habe.
Die Amis hatten einfach ein massives Problem. Die haben das Bewusstsein hier bei den Europäern auch nicht so richtig wecken können, mit ihren Kanälen, die sie da hatten. Und die Bundespost hat mit den Schultern gezuckt.
Aber nicht in dem Fall.
Nein, aber auch nur, weil da massiv Druck gemacht wurde. Es war schon schwierig für einen Staat, für einen anderen Staat, das klarzumachen, dass da was passieren muss. Und wahrscheinlich musste da auch gar nichts passieren. Also es gibt ja da immer verschiedene Ebenen von Wahrheiten. Und meine Wahrheit in diesem ganzen KGB-Fall, die speist sich halt aus meinem Erleben. Ich hab gewisse Sachen selbst erlebt und weiß, dass ich in Ostberlin war. Ich weiß, dass es da jemanden gab, der Russe war oder so, jedenfalls so rüber kam, als wäre er Russe und so weiter. Aber es gibt da sicherlich eine ganz große Wahrheitsplane, die sich mir nicht erschließt. Da kann ich jetzt drüber spekulieren, ob Clifford Stoll von der US-Regierung als Agent eingesetzt wurde, damit das Ganze hier mal irgendwie hochgekocht wird. Vielleicht war der Russe auch nur ein Avogadarm-Provokateur. Aber was soll ich mir jetzt darüber Gedanken machen? Ich glaube, das führt dann eigentlich zu nichts. Aber man kann schon sagen, dass unsere Aktivitäten, und da bin ich jetzt nicht stolz drauf, dass unsere Aktivitäten eine unglaubliche Paranoia und eine unglaubliche Panik erweckt haben, was Hacker eigentlich tun könnten. Da war plötzlich die Block-Konfrontation, und da war der Russe in amerikanischen Rechnern.
Die Berichterstattung war ja auch wirklich absurd.
Da wurde in einer Art und Weise dann auch...
Der größte Spionagefall seit Gion.
Das war so derartig lachhaft. Vor allem, weil es wirklich inhaltlich war. Ich kann nicht sagen, was die anderen gemacht haben. Ich kann nur sagen, was ich so weiß. Das war alles Pelle Palle. Das ist alles nichts, was von strategischem oder auch nur taktischem Interesse wäre in einem irgendwie gearteten Konfliktfall.
Also was jetzt an Daten da erinnert wurde?
Ja, was an Daten geartet wurde oder was wir an Zugängen hatten. Wir hatten kein komplettes Bild. Wir konnten keine Lagebeurteilung machen. Wir konnten keine strategischen Systeme kontrollieren. Und was ist das denn dann? Dann ist das gar nichts. Wenn ich jetzt mal danach gehe, was die Russen von uns wollten, haben die ja auch so gesehen. Die wollten hier, wir haben irgendwie Probleme, an den Cobol Compiler Source Code Version 5.0 ranzukommen. Und unsere Leute brauchen das Scheißding. Also könnt ihr das beschaffen? Hier gibt es 5.000, dann ist der Deal. Aber mit Hackern und mit irgendwie...
Da frage ich mich natürlich, wie kam es zu dieser Aufbauschung? Also ich meine jetzt, dieser Stol hat halt irgendwie Alarm geschlagen. Aus welchen Gründen auch immer war ausgerechnet seine Entdeckung, wenn es denn eine war, hat dazu geführt, dass auch in Deutschland erheblich geforscht wurde. Dann wurde eben einer aus dem Team irgendwie erst mal festgenommen, weil er eben als Originator dieser Hackereien festgenommen wurde. Und dann, wie kam denn dann der Bogen überhaupt auf diesen Fall mit den Russen? Weil dann irgendwie unter Vernehmungsdruck irgendwie...
Moment mal, wie war denn das? Ich muss jetzt noch mal die zeitliche Reihenfolge da richtig kriegen.
Kriege ich nämlich jetzt auch nicht so ohne weiteres zusammen.
Ich glaube doch aber, dass Clifford Stoll nach den KGB-Aktivitäten war, aber bevor das Ganze hier richtig rausgekommen ist, und richtig rausgekommen ist, das hier, weil Carl gegen die Wand gefahren ist. Weil Carl nämlich irgendwie, da diesen ultrabrutalen Drogenabsturz hatte, dann in der Psyche gelandet ist, dann aus der Psyche wieder rausgekommen ist und dann auf irgendwie ultrakrassen Medikamenten war, aber immer noch mit Kucker und immer noch nicht von dem Film runter, der es erst erleuchtete, und dann angefangen hat rumzuquatschen. So ist das Ganze dann rausgekommen. Als Stolzbuch rauskam, oder diese Stollgeschichte da rauskam, da hatten wir alle unsere Köppe schon wieder eingezogen gehabt. Also ich hatte ja sowieso mich da relativ früh wieder rausgezogen, und ich glaube, da war das schon so weitgehend vorbei. Ja, so, ja. Aber laut Stolzbuch haben die ja festgestellt, dass da gezielt nach bestimmten militärischen Informationen gesucht wurde. Weil der russische Kontaktmann uns ja auch gesagt hat, ja entweder ihr liefert das, oder wir sind also an richtigen Militärzugängen natürlich auch interessiert, das würden wir dann prüfen. Aber es war so, ich kann mir auch vorstellen, auf welcher Ebene das abläuft. Der Typ handelt halt mit Software. Und wenn er dann irgendwie da in Russland am Tisch sitzt und mal irgendwelche KGB-Offiziellen da hat, und er dann so, ja guck mal, Accounts von Mami, denke vielleicht so. Aber das war ja nie die Rede davon, dass wir irgendwas hätten, was die wirklich haben wollten. Das war ja überhaupt gar nichts.
Und diese Person, mit der jeder Kontakt hatte, die war jetzt auch nicht im einlichen Sinne vom Karibi?
Nein, der hat sich vorgestellt als Mitarbeiter der russischen Handelsmission. Ja, man kann ja jetzt alles mögliche, aber natürlich, der hat einfach mit Koko-Ware gehandelt. Das war halt ein Händler. Natürlich haben die russischen Händler, die dann mit KGB-Protektion und so weiter waren, die haben sich dann auch in der DDR einigermaßen bewegen können und konnten auch die Grenzkontrollen und so, aber das war alles, ach naja.
Nichts Besonderes im einigen Sinne. Das musste halt gemacht werden. Na ja, aus Sicht des Ostblocks, der durch diese Kokon-Gesetzgebung eben nicht an alles rankam. Schon nachvollziehbar.
Und die Aufdeckungsgeschichte von Cliff Stoll, die hat, glaube ich, folgende Essenz. Es war für die amerikanischen Behörden sehr schwierig, die Deutschen ausreichend zu sensibilisieren, dass da was passieren muss. Weil die Deutschen irgendwie, ach nee, was soll da sein und so? Nee, interessiert uns nicht. Und wie? Die kommen in euren geheimen militärischen Computern rein. Das konnten die ja auch nicht gut sagen, weißt du? Ich glaube, für die amerikanische Seite war einfach das Problem, dass die das genervt hat und dass die das auch nicht wollten und dass die aber wollten, dass das auch abgestellt wird. Jetzt nicht in dem Sinne, dass da jetzt irgendwie die nationale Sicherheit der USA beeinträchtigt ist, aber dass hier in Europa und in Deutschland da wohl die bunte Lust herrscht und die Hacker da machen können, was sie wollen. Das geht ja wirklich nicht.
Ein rechtsfreier Raum.
Und ich glaube, dafür war das Buch da und dafür war es auch gut, weil es eben locker flockig diese Problematik in die Köpfe reingebracht hat und in der Folge dann auch die Hackergesetzgebungen hier verschärft wurden und so weiter. Also das hat schon seinen Effekt gehabt.
Tja, das Internet und die Hackereien. Ist jetzt nicht mehr ganz so aufregend alles, zumindest nicht auf dem Level.
Das glaubst du.
Ja, ich wollte es auch gerade einschränken. Ist natürlich so eine Unterwelt, die schwer zu beleuchten ist. Hast du da noch irgendwelche Einblicke, wie sich solche Aktivitäten heute darstellen? Es gibt da riesige Märkte, wo Exploits verkauft werden.
Ich kann mir das nur vorstellen. Ich hab da weder Interesse noch Aktien drin, weil ich Computersicherheit ziemlich langweilig finde. Ich wollte ja auch damals nur eine Wechs haben. Sicherheit hat mich damals auch nicht interessiert. Aber ich glaube, dass es eben schon noch, sag ich mal, Sachen gibt, die Zecken, wo man als Teenager Bock drauf haben kann. Wenn es jetzt darum geht, eine Million PCs zu kontrollieren, das klingt schon gut. Und das können auch nicht viele, und das ist der gleiche Art. Ich glaube, da wird eben genauso wie bei uns damals auch sehr gerne so ein Alarm geschlagen, weil man es halt einfach kann, weil eine Story sich besser verkauft, wenn es eine Story ist und nicht nur irgendeine Geschichte, weißt du. Also das wird das alles nicht so furchtbar hoch aufhängen, aber es ist halt so, dass die gleiche Motivation, die für uns damals bestanden hat, dass es die eben auch noch gibt. Es gibt die Top 500 Supercomputer-Liste, die ist ein würdiges Ziel, es gibt den ICFP-Programmierwettbewerb, die ist ein Ziel, oder es gibt Botnetze, die man bauen kann. Und ich glaube, dass das alles existiert und dass man gut daran tut, das nicht zu hoch aufzuhängen, sondern das eben einfach so zu sehen, wie es ist. Das macht Spaß. Die Leute, die das machen, die das wirklich machen, die machen das nicht für Geld. Die machen das, weil es ihnen so viel Spaß macht, dass sie einfach nicht davon lassen können. Und natürlich ist es scheiße, wenn die Situation eintritt, dass damit Geld verdient werden kann. Aber das ist letztlich so das Hacker-Thema, das kennen wir ja. Alle Hacker müssen aufeinander aufpassen, dass wenn jemand so was macht, dass der eben trotzdem nicht an die falschen Leute gerät dabei. Das geht öfter mal schief und bei mir ist es letztlich ja dann auch schiefgegangen. So kann man auch so sehen.
Was ist denn dein Rat für die Jugend von heute, für den tempted Hacker, der vor dem großen Tor steht?
Ich habe da kein Rat zu geben. Ich meine, ich habe ja wie gesagt, ich habe ja meine Fehler gemacht. Und was heißt Fehler gemacht? Ich würde auch sagen, ich bin überhaupt nicht in der Situation, irgendwie irgendeinen Rat zu geben. Ich bin immer noch genauso wahnsinnig und bin immer noch genauso, wenn mich irgendetwas halt so anmacht, dass ich es machen will, dann mache ich das halt einfach. Und dann, vielleicht bin ich heute, weil ich irgendwie Kinder habe und so, nicht mehr zu so vielen Opfern bereit oder zu jedem Blödsinn bereit. Aber jetzt so einen Rat zu geben, ich meine, das macht einfach Spaß. Und das bringt letztlich auch die Welt irgendwie weiter, wenn man hackt. Ich finde schon, dass man hacken soll.
Das finde ich auch. Ich finde, das war ein gutes Schlusswort, Hans.
Das sind wir ja ganz schön abgewichen noch, du hattest doch die…
Nee, das ist alles super. Das ist alles super. Ich liebe auch das Abweichen, das gehört hier auf jeden Fall auch zum Programm. Und letzten Endes mag ich es auch lieber, wenn sich Gespräche organisch entwickeln und ihre Themen selber finden, als dass man irgendeine Outline nimmt und einen Plan reinschmeißt. Weißt du, dann wird es aber auch nicht mehr, als man sich das vorher mal gedacht hat.
Gut, ich hoffe, dass wir nicht zu viel Enttäuschung produzieren.
Nein, ich denke, das war ein sehr interessanter Einblick in eine Zeit, die schwer nachzuvollziehen ist. Ich meine, sogar für mich war das damals schwer nachzuvollziehen. Ich war nicht so in x-File, ich war überall so ein bisschen auch mal unterwegs, aber ich habe bis beileibe da nicht so viel Zeit drin versenkt, wie du und viele andere. So das Mailbox-Leben und so, die ganzen Datenkommunikationen, überhaupt dieses ganze Aufkommen des Internets und all dieser Netze, die dort sozusagen anstanden, erforscht zu werden. Das ist halt damals einfach das aufregende Ding in der digitalen Welt gewesen. Das wird so nicht wiederkommen, ganz klar. Das war jetzt einmal die Geburtsstunde, die gibt es nur einmal. Dieses spezielle Gefühl kenne ich gut. Ich bin der Chef von der Welt. Aber man fühlt sich natürlich schon extrem privilegiert, wenn man daran eben dann auch so live teilnehmen kann. Ich kann nur hoffen, dass es in Zukunft noch großartige Dinge gibt, in denen alle auf die gleiche Art und Weise teilnehmen können.
Ich bin mir vollständig sicher, denn wie gesagt, in den letzten 20 Jahren ist nicht so viel passiert, wie man glauben möchte.
Das ist immer noch die ganz alte Scheiße. Es gibt sogar noch Unix. Nun gut, Hans, ich bedanke mich. Das war es, Chaosradio Express, die einhundertstelste Folge. Und sie sollte etwas Besonderes sein. Ich denke, das ist sie auch geworden. Ich bedanke mich hier auf jeden Fall auch nochmal bei euch für das ganze Zuhören in den mittlerweile drei Jahren, die ich das Ganze jetzt so mache. Ich habe diese hundertlange Zeit auch vor mir hergeschoben und werde auch demnächst ein paar Neuigkeiten verkünden, wie ich das hier alles so zu gestalten gedenke. Aber das kommt jetzt nicht mehr in diese Datei, sondern in eine andere. Sagen wir mal Danke, Hans.
Ja, passt auf euch auf.
Genau, passt euch auf auf. Das war der Blick in die Vergangenheit des Internets und der deutschen Hackergeschichte. Und ja, passt euch auf euch auf und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.